hello
friends
and enemies that's right enemies too who
are trying to triangulate our
undisclosed location you will never find
where we are recording from
no intelligence service will ever
penetrate
our headquarters
we are underground
we're we're in pyongyang we're in the
democratic people's republic of korea
yeah what are they going to do come over
exactly you'll never actually we are we
are underground under the stake hut
in maximum security and curacao i think
they upgraded
they mossed them no they they're still
there as far as the as far as i know
they're i mean that's a nice hut yeah
they're not yeah they if they were fake
they would have moved up you know what i
mean they would have gotten like a nicer
they don't forget their roots yeah
exactly they stay true respect that so
anyway welcome everybody to leftovers uh
episode 17. okay
um how are you today hassan
i'm i'm doing all right i'm doing pretty
good i boxed a little bit last night you
know you have a clip of it should i
watch it wait there's a clip of me
boxing or well something of the sword oh
no you didn't know this was out there no
i did not i probably looked terrible
what is this boot camp you all are just
boxing
yeah we were learning how to [ __ ]
duck and stuff yeah so and we i guess
there's not much going on here with you
i had a really
for me specifically i had a really hard
time not exaggerating my movements
because i'm just like
i've been hit in the face a lot when i
was in college i've been in fights
before you got punched in the face in
college a lot yeah why no [ __ ] i
don't know what were you fighting about
wild one you know i don't know people
i was in new jersey [ __ ] get
crazy in new jersey like
it's like a thing people did you beat
the [ __ ] out of it of people because
you're a big guy um i've definitely won
some fights for sure but i always say
like you don't actually win anything
like even if you win a fight you don't
actually win a fight you know what i
mean you know actually i've seen people
lose fights and i've i've lost fights
too for sure really you got your ass
i've gotten suckers punched i've gotten
uh i've gotten like multiple people uh
jumped me into no but wait what's going
on are you just like drunk outside a
club i mean really what are you fighting
about um it's usually stuff like that
uh i've gotten a fight before for like
people being homophobic
oh really yeah
but
it's just
it's mostly just like drunk of stupidity
honestly
there's a lot of aggro i didn't take
that i didn't take you for a fighter i'm
not i'm not gonna be honest i'm not a
very uh
i'm a lover not a fighter for sure
i uh i hate fighting thank you thank you
guys
i personally hate fighting but there's a
lot of of uh people
inside of the state of new jersey that
love to fight sure especially when they
you know when they get drunk and they
get angry and they're like [ __ ] man i
live in new jersey i hate that [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah you know box me [ __ ] yeah i
mean the last time i was in a fight was
fifth grade uh next to the wall ball
court
we got in a fight over who who was next
he put me in a headlock and started
punching my head bro like unexpectedly
that's crazy yeah it was hardcore i was
like damn it's just wall ball dude chill
yeah his dad probably beat him or
something most likely i don't know i
just
don't fight it's not good it's not a
good idea um unless you're doing it like
like boxing for for cardio and stuff in
which case it is great exercise i mean i
got my ass beat last night
not literally but you know cardio wise
it was great well today we have kind of
a mega episode about ben shapiro and all
the guys at the daily wire who have been
on an absolute tear of homophobia and
transphobia these men are they've been
killing it
there's something going on with them
like what
where is this coming from guys
i think they're just
they just stand bigotry like they're
they're just like overall like bigotry
weebs you know what i mean they're just
like we've this is our moment like
bigotry's back in a big way i mean it
never kind of went away
for for the most part but it was like
unacceptable to like be overtly
homophobic until
until recently i would say oh they
they're like yeah finally dude they're
bringing it back
yeah actually i and and you guys will
notice in the title it says you know
bench appeal is a manlet or whatever but
let me justify that before anyone gets
angry okay
let me show you ben shapiro
uh
full body because the thing is we love
our
short kings here uh we have nothing but
love and respect
the short kings of of of the world but
these are manlets and it's important
that you know the distinction
he's not just short in stature he's
short in
you know
i'm a defender i'm a defender of
shortcase consistently a short king uh
champion if you will i'm a champion of
short king's rights
uh
there's a there's a clear distinction
between a man and a short king for sure
um damn where'd this photo i had a photo
of like what's up to cody cole noah
miller dude you got it you don't gotta
name and shame them bro it's not even
wait why would i but they're kings
they're literally so i don't okay so
it's like what other
wait is noel sure
no yeah oh is he really yeah
king
short kings the short people tend to
flock to each other i've noticed
i wish they flocked to me like i want to
i want to carry him around you know what
i mean oh see that's demeaning no i want
to put you i want to put you on my back
and just you know that's baby bjorn that
that's demeaning no no no no dude all i
i'm can you guys find a picture of there
was a picture of ben shapiro matt walsh
and that other goon what's his name
standing next to each other
and by the way ben shapiro's sister is
kind of hot
abigail shapiro oh because i type i get
started i i bench barrel full body and
all i see is his
is his sister who's like
oh no wet ass
giving me a little bit of a whack i want
to talk about
wait no this isn't
damn she got some mommy milkers bro okay
okay let's not let's not let's not get
in there let's not go there no ethan
it's not a good that's not a good space
to be in wait why it's just because i
mean you know sometimes you know when
something is true but you just don't
have to point to it you know it's like
that wait why don't we point to
something that's true it's just we don't
need to talk about it i mean yes she's a
very attractive woman um
that's crazy because she looks so much
like ben well decorated i mean yeah also
taller than ben which is interesting
yeah no she got all the she got all the
good stuff
wet ass p word can i just uh say real
quick um i have seen about six or seven
chat messages and somebody just sent me
a screenshot as well i think because we
have daily wire in the title everybody's
getting daily wire ads on this nice well
that's great so they're paying us and
nobody
nobody's clicking that right this
episode's brought to you by the daily
every one of my videos i think they like
i don't know what it is but i think they
just like bought out my entire channel
inventory or something like every one of
my videos is like matt walsh ads or
daily wire ads which is so funny that's
so interesting that they have apparently
found that it's worth it to promote
their channel i think that's so much
money they don't give a [ __ ] yeah it's
possible like they're just like we are
gonna flood the market
um can where did i find that photo
nobody's got me i mean
oh yeah this is it so
again just to address the manlet thing
so here's ben shapiro as we know he's
like what four nine
five two five two candace owen so what's
interesting is not allowed to wear heels
in the office
right right right right should flat
souls only yeah
they're like come on candice and then
what's this guy's name he's uh he these
guys are all so hateful it's incredible
i mean this is like uh that's that's
mainly american fascist conference uh
that's michael knowles who uh debated uh
on fox like on the local fox news he's a
real piece of work too eh oh yeah he's
great he was like
he was like a big like advocate for
i think he's like an anti-vaxxer too
which is not that surprising uh the only
person the daily wire team is that's
like
kind of lightly pro-vaxxed is ben
everyone else is like pretty much on
that anti-vaxx train too but he was like
definitely heavily
like
you know anti-masking at that time
here's jordan with his son
uh his great admirer ben shapiro yeah
[ __ ] you and then well stop jordan where
see but that's like so this is a great
example right like because uh your
height doesn't define uh you becoming a
monstrous piece of [ __ ] no no because
like jordan peterson apparently is tall
yeah and also right that that that's our
point we're just the thing is and matt
walsh he's actually just 5'4 but he's
hulking over
these other guys
so there's something about going on at
the daily wire these are manlet and i
want you to understand the difference
between manlet and short kings and
that's why we use the term manlet right
thank you thank you for your support
there's a yeah we love all of our short
games
[Applause]
danny devito peter dinklage uh
who else i mean he's a lot of short king
excuse me yeah look at this here's ads
that you just got this ab yeah oh my god
i didn't realize putting daily in the
wire daily wire in the
in the title just gets us paid bro
i just want to point out look at those
eyebrows
yeah there's a whole eyebrow conspiracy
too yeah ben shapiro you think he paints
it yes he's got like a like an anthony
davis thing going on even though he's
anthony davis natty
well there's clear actually we have
evidence of the eyebrow conspiracy
because there is clear before and after
evidence that i'd like to present to you
okay i would like to see this that shows
that ben shapiro does in fact yeah pain
we don't do investigative reporting on
the leftovers and they're wrong okay
this is this is it the new york times is
crying right now yeah
they could never yeah yeah well in the
meantime ethan klein scooped me on the
eyebrow thing [ __ ]
no he's [ __ ] done after this
um as you guys are do we have that in
the docker i saw that somewhere it was
uh it was in the dock last week let me
uh let me dig it up anyway as you guys
find that um
let's just pull up some top of the show
goodies for example elon musk
who is now the uh prominent conservative
thinker of the world
has endorsed
this lady a republican candidate
uh named mara flores yeah
and he voted for her first time ever
voting republican
and just to put it in context she is a
um
she is a q anon person an anti-vaxx so
um
there's so many goodies in that in that
little twitter thread where he's like
responding to people but like why are
you even being like oh my god this is
the first time i've voted for a
republican you're a billionaire dog you
literally have given hundreds of
thousands of dollars to republicans
across the [ __ ] board anyway like who
gives a [ __ ] if you're one singular vote
for a republican like yeah okay sick
dude he's such a fraud like he goes i'm
buying twitter
and i'm going to ensure that it's not a
political body meanwhile he's like i'm
voting for this q a conspiracy theorist
massive red wave 2022
let's go
no no that's perfect though he said
remember how he said i'm gonna do a in
that twitter third he talks about i'm
gonna do a pack for like moderates yeah
he wants to build like a moderate pack
or centres and then he says he's gonna
vote for desantis for president it's
like you just gave the game away dumbass
you can't just say like oh that that's
what this is anytime someone says
they're a [ __ ] moderate on the
internet or anywhere else okay if they
say they're a centrist understand that
they're just center right or far right
and they're just lying to you and maybe
even lying to themselves okay because
what the [ __ ] is moderate about ron
death santa who like literally sick the
gestapo on his own
uh scientists in the public health
administration of florida for like
releasing actual covet fatality numbers
and [ __ ] you know what i mean or ron
death santas who's most notable for uh i
don't know like murder gay teenager
bills and [ __ ] like that like that well
don't say gay yeah is that but but the
thing is the problem is ron desantis
who's obviously a a hog in his own right
is um
he's moderate compared to donald trump
who's just an unhinged
but he's not but he's not i don't think
rhonda sanchez is moderate in comparison
to donald trump think for example i
don't think ron desantis would try to
overthrow an election i don't think he'd
do that you are so wrong i 100 think
rhonda i don't think so i don't i think
one i don't think he would be calling
like the georgia like secretary of state
or whatever and being like i need to
find 7 000 votes no he would be more
petty republicans have stolen a florida
election already that's how george w
bush became president famously
in the aftermath of the brooks brothers
riots the people that were involved in
that three of them that were
tangentially involved now sit on the
supreme court three lawyers that were
involved in the brooks brothers riots
and the subsequent uh supreme court
decision that came down three of those
lawyers are now in the supreme court as
supreme court justices this has always
been a republican strategy republicans
don't want to win elections they don't
give a [ __ ] about that they just want to
they want to game the system as best as
they can
or even outright sidestep congress in
its entirety
um
and i do think that ron desantis if push
game the show would be even scarier than
donald trump because he's i think more
competent than donald trump i i i hear
you but i don't think he's as overtly
[ __ ] psycho as i don't know donald
trump is next level in my opinion we
haven't found we haven't found a
politician
that like
captures
the the attention
of uh the voter base in the way that
donald trump does that also
simultaneously is competent because his
donald trump's incompetence kind of
makes him like an outsider which is also
the reason why people like him you know
what i mean some people in his base like
him um but as far as like uh you know
being a vector for all of their anger
and frustration directed at the exact
same villains that the republican party
has been directing their attention to
donald trump and ron desantis are the
exact same gay people
immigrants
uh poor people homeless people like
these are
these are considered uh the the main
enemy of the republican party in
perpetuity uh and and that's it's that's
the same enemies that ron desantis uh
also has ron desantis famously remember
uh
overturned the the results
of the florida felon voter restoration
uh ballot measure that passed in florida
by a wider margin than ron desantis did
like win the gubernatorial race and he
overturned it he instituted what is
known as a poll tax basically in the
state of florida for felons who were for
the first time ever going to be able to
vote again
and he said you can't vote until you pay
all your debts to uh the courts oh yeah
i remember that that's that's illegal
isn't it i mean that seems
unconstitutional the poll tax it is
precise that's what i mean poll taxes is
like
vestiges of jim crow
that's exactly what it is well here's
elon musk saying i'm thinking of
creating a super
moderate pac
that supports candidates with central
centrist views from all parties what he
means by that is
people from both parties who will not
increase my taxes or and will not
regulate how i treat my employees which
by the way ironically
most
both parties are not going to do that so
don't worry about it he basically just
means anyone who's not aoc or people
that actually care about workers rights
yeah speaking of workers rights i should
mention that later in the episode we
have
one of the
workers from starbucks who uh
unionized participated in the
unionization
star buckos
and she's going to be calling in
so there you have that
um
so i have the update on benchmare's
eyebrows okay all right let's see so
this is the hard-hitting
stuff that people come to expect excited
all right
this is breaking news
[Music]
so
we have discussed
just guys just how am i supposed to find
this
with peace and love
thank you
yeah that's why i didn't send a discord
is that
okay so as you can see
his eyebrows are very very thick very
caterpillar-esque there yeah in that
shot but if we go down
this is in this is you know
they're not as thick there
now he has thick eyebrows don't get me
wrong yeah but there's a
distinct difference between those
eyebrows and go up please
and these eyebrows 100
he laid it on he laid on the the he
colored it in way too much now look at
this
this is just out of control my dude he
is trying to look more masculine to make
up for the fact that he's four nine
i think i don't i don't think he can
grow facial hair that's why he's just
like trying to improve wherever he is
right wherever there's hair that he
could grow on a space but now here
not as even not as filled out
yeah yeah it's not as thick there's a
gap there yeah yeah
don't you paint it like you can paint it
that's what he does that's what he does
but go down now
now here's little ben shapiro
normal eyebrows but he's a child he's a
child
i mean he's playing the violin maybe
like the more racist he got the more
powerful his eyebrows got you ever think
about that
that's quite possible he was a kid like
you know every time like tchaikovsky or
whatever he was like he was like not
racist yet
and then he learned about like how
racist he could be and then his eyebrows
started growing it's it's rumored that
every time a gay kid gets beat up uh ben
shapiro gets a new eyebrow hair yeah
he's just like he's just growing more
powerful every time hate crimes are
happening but now look at ben shapiro
here he's a grown man
eyebrows
not as distinct not even close and i'm
sorry but since i graduated college my
eyebrows have not gotten thicker they've
stayed the same
it's true
yeah i mean
and then or okay here's the alternative
so now hold on hold on hold on hold on
so take a look at this one take it in
now go all the way back up to the top
dan to where we are today oh my god that
does not [ __ ] add okay ladies and
gentlemen
i rest my case okay i have an
alternative theory
ben
lost in the in the height department
yeah gene pool yeah
so
you know it beefed up his eyebrow stats
so instead of growing because he can't
grow since fifth grade like daredevil
it's grown as his eyebrows
like daredevil he's blind so his ears
during
exactly that's exactly what i mean yeah
that's interesting
yeah he's got super powerful eyebrows
his height stops growing his uh his dump
stat in dnd yeah right right right it's
his superpower
i don't know bro those eyebrows are
that's some heart that's some
uh goddamn steve harvey's mustache be
sitting over his eyes he's just
he looks like eugene levy with those big
ass eyebrows he he he has like one of
the eyebrows like larger than the other
so that i don't know what happened there
that is a very strange thing yeah that
one is like bigger right it's like
thicker
that's the reason
i mean good for him like you know he i
don't think he can grow facial air so
he's just like trying to grow eyebrow
hair and i respect that good for him but
uh so look then there's there's
again these people we're talking about
today are are like i mean the worst
hateful [ __ ] disgusting beasts
who walk this planet currently more or
less here's lo and lauren bobert
who had a big scandal actually come out
we'll talk about that but you know in
the in the wake of this horrible
shooting in texas as we're all familiar
with
uh gun control has been a hotly
debated issue here's lauren's take on
this
on twitter a lot of the
the little twitter trolls they like to
say
oh jesus didn't need an ar-15 how many
ar-15s do you think jesus would have had
well he didn't have enough to keep his
government from killing him that's right
is she doing big is she doing a bit
jesus was supposed to die you dumb ass
christian
he wasn't supposed to overtake the
romans that's the whole point of the
whole jesus story you dummy i love that
i love that she's at like a christian
gathering and like they even they were
like they're like
yeah they're like i was a little bit of
sac religious uh you know hubris right
there what the [ __ ] was that also like
like she did a jeb bush please laugh
moment does she like double take totally
please laugh
yeah we gotta sound bite that by the way
zach please laugh okay yo but
it's like
that's god he could have he didn't need
the air 15 so that's what they're
thinking they're like how dare you
question the power of jesus no i love
that it's just but it's perfect because
i mean obviously just joking it's like
such a bad joke
it's such a bad one that like no
people don't even laugh at first and
then they're like oh [ __ ] we're supposed
to clap at this one okay all right
lauren yeah but it's good to see she
really filled out the seats there in the
at the christian camp the christian hate
camp
um
i love that i love this take these are
these are unique takes and i
as a man who looks at takes every day
for a living i i do appreciate it when
they go buck wild like this cause i'm
like well i've never heard that before
so i i like it so i celebrate lauren
bobert for that one i love that yeah he
just said that you
yeah so lauren bober
who is one of these just terrible
terrible new like neo conservatives who
basically just run solely on hate and
ignorance
this year she got or this week she got
called out by these guys called the
muckrakers
and these are the savages and i don't
use that word lightly who literally
destroyed
madison kothal for humping his cousin's
face cawthorne yeah catholic
muckracker's pac uh muckracker's pack is
uh a group of like real aggro liberals
right look at this is the most the
face of the most savage people on earth
go ahead azan i just wanted to tee this
up while you're getting owned by these
guys bro they look like accountants
look at this savage go ahead yeah i
didn't want to i didn't mean to
interrupt you i just wanted to run this
no no no i i respect that so muckraker's
pack is like they they remind me of like
bush era liberalism where like they were
way more combative even though some of
the dudes i think on there are like
ex-conservatives too
which they're they're kind of like doing
a lincoln project thing uh
in some ways but you know they're
they're doing a good job they're like
completely [ __ ] psychotic and
i like that
because one first they're not training
their sites on the left like the
democratic party often does because
democratic party usually is just
only brutal to the left and like treats
the right with baby gloves you know and
i mean they're like oh no like let's not
offend the right like
um these guys are like not [ __ ] that
we're we're doing the same [ __ ] that
republicans would do
uh so it's about time i think like
they're that they're uh there's a like a
psychotic [ __ ] pack that's just
bouldering these weirdos and let's be
honest you know
when you look at like
democrats who got canceled like uh al
franken who literally had to resign in
disgrace because some dumb photo he took
yeah uh this on the meanwhile
is actually juicy for the reason that
lauren bobert is like a painful [ __ ]
disgusting hypocrite she's against
for the record i don't believe the the
allegations you don't oh no i don't
believe i mean it can't it is but they
didn't miss the scope of reason
especially like knowing what i know
about lauren bobert which ironically
this pack didn't actually show
too much of
which is like the real verifiable proven
things that she has done that are like
incredibly strange
um well her husband's a sex offender we
know that yeah her husband is uh well
her husband is not just a sex offender
he also beat her
um oh well that's when they got married
yeah that's normal yeah that's like
basic yeah it's basic [ __ ] from rifle
colorado baby uh but her one-third of
all cops her husband was 24 years old
when he whipped his [ __ ] out uh at a
bowling alley
and in front of minors and lauren bobert
was there yeah as a minor as a 17 year
old and that's the beginning of a nice
love story yeah so he was like yeah i've
got a dick tattoo like and then he just
whipped his dick out
and you know the police came and they
arrested him that's awesome
four days
um
that's not featured in here for some
weird reason i don't know why because i
feel like that's way way more um
i mean that there's there's proof well
hold on so the allegations are the thing
is i i like to pretend that i i like to
believe it just because these guys
didn't miss with madison but they allege
okay that she was a paid escort on a
website called
sugardaddymeetno.com now there's nothing
wrong with these allegations it's only
uh it's only juicy because she is a
family values christian who wants to
outlaw abortion because it also alleges
she had two abortions
one which was at planned parenthood
which is which if is true
makes her a [ __ ] absolute
monster trying to remove the right
for other women to get abortions after
she got one
from planned parenthood
but i'm hoping hassan
that they've got more in the pipeline
because they did the same thing with
madison
yeah so so i'm hoping they have more
supporting evidence here so those photos
that they're showcasing yeah right to
say that she's like sugar daddy uh
the reason why this could potentially be
true even though i don't believe it is i
don't think there's enough evidence at
this moment for it to be real
but
um the reason why i think that it could
be true is because she's on
exploretalent.com which is an aggregator
of uh all these other like modeling and
uh modeling networks
and
uh it's something that like everyone in
america that ever wanted to like be in
hollywood has participated in in some
capacity i know this isn't i've been
living here for 10 years like all my
friends have like explore talent you
know probably like old-ass explore
talent uh pages
right
she had one as well we looked it up it's
on the way back
uh these photos are taken from the
explore talent oh so what the hell i
feel a little
click-baited because it's a it's a
modeling website but i mean this does
i could see her being like uh you know
they've got more white trash uh escort
doing doing stuff like that yes well
then the best part about the allegations
is that apparently again alleged that
ted cruz
[ __ ] her
i don't believe that come
boy it's too good hey cruz i feel like
ted cruz he looks like a melted candle
wax like his penis probably doesn't
function bro it does
he shoots lava out of his [ __ ] instead
of semen um no so the thing is like when
you make out with the ted cruz he just
he just
he passes tonsil stones to you oh
remember when he spit a tonsil stone out
during the debate
so when he makes out with you it's like
a bubble gum machine for
console stones
ted cruz probably like i mean this is
nasty as [ __ ] but let's just go with it
i guess ted cruz probably tastes like
like the acid reflux like all the right
stomach acid is so powerful you have
acid reflux forever i love that god
punishes you for kissing ted cruz in the
mouth that was not something you were
supposed to do okay
yeah and you deserve it that's true
but i will say this is the worst website
i've ever seen one of them since like
the 90s i'm not sure what the [ __ ] is
wrong with i know it it was driving me
nuts when i was like like
yeah there's [ __ ] boomers the the
logo guys
you're saying she's trash but anyway i'm
hoping there's more coming out because i
want this to be real so bad so but like
there's there's real stuff there that
one of the funniest uh things that they
uncovered which i do 100 believe by the
way
is the uh the quad incident
she's in utah she's driving a 4x4 with
her
child and her sister-in-law
she's drunk
allegedly gets in an accident and then
bails which is ironic because that's
very similar to madison cawthorn
who also
famously got into a car accident and
then bailed and then uh or
rather was saved by
uh uh one of the people in the accident
and then lied
and said that uh you know
they they left them behind
well we heard from a friend of the show
pmp the tick tock lawyer that the isis
is to run if you get into a drunk
driving accident so that was actually a
smart move on her part this is what you
if you make out with ted cruz you can
get a little taste of uh
america's finest i mean he's i'm not
wearing my glasses
who doesn't want to kiss that man
i'm taking my glasses off i don't need
to see i just tell you freshly baked
tonsil stone for you to i've seen too
much dude i don't want to see any more
than i have
oh god he's beautiful stop it
yeah so she hit and run
and she left
her
yeah she got into a drunk quadding
accident which sounds so sorry white
trash as [ __ ] sounds like something
keemstar would do which by the way is
sick like i love quads i love the white
trash [ __ ] like i'm a big fan of all the
white trash activities so
that's why i'm saying like this sounds
exactly within the realm of reason yeah
and then like there's nothing
there's nothing more like conservative
uh middle america than [ __ ] leaving
your family behind after you uh cause
like almost vehicular manslaughter how
was that middle america thing just
leaving your family to burn
it's just i think that's like a classic
lauren bober thing like i could see her
doing i want to put that on all of
middle of america though some people are
just p you're right some people are just
pieces of [ __ ] and they exactly i mean
kennedy did that he [ __ ] let dude
that was one of the great kennedy moves
yeah so some people are pieces of [ __ ]
i'm just saying that like
i'm saying that doing it in a quartering
instead of
makes it so like yeah perfectly uh piece
of [ __ ] middle america
if it was in like a kennedy situation if
it was in the [ __ ] back uh if it was
in the [ __ ] backseat of your like
mercedes that you dump into the [ __ ]
river then it's like very
uh it's more of a buy coastal elite
thing you know that was that was a great
one um
drunkenly crashed into a lake bailed and
the girl inside drowned yeah left her
there to die
that's something that's
the latest piece of [ __ ] activity oh and
then the other great thing about the
kennedys uh their dog the youngest
sister was too sexually active and they
[ __ ] lobotomized her
you didn't know that
what yeah they [ __ ] lobotomized her
dude wait pull that up dude
you didn't know that about that it's so
good i
no literally was lobotomized because she
was too promiscuous
okay now i gotta put the glasses back on
i gotta see this okay let's see uh here
lobotomy go go to number two
according to rosemary
sorry zooming in according to rosemary's
sister when rosemary returned the united
states from the uk in 1940 she regressed
she later stated that rosemary became
increasingly irritable and difficult at
the age 22.
okay this is saying that she was just
like irritable and difficult and even
violent and that's why they lobotomized
there
rosemary was sent to the covenant school
rosemary began sneaking out for girls
nights the nuns at all the cabinets
thought that she must be involved with
sexual partners and that she could
contract the std or become pregnant her
occasional erratic behavior
frustrated her parents her father was
especially worried that rosemary
behavior would shame the family
when rosemary was 23 years old doctor
told her father that a form of
psychosurgery known as lobotomy would
help calm her mood swings and stop her
occasional outburst how wild is that the
doctors were just like we need to plug a
hole in your [ __ ] brain but she was
literally just a young girl who was
going out having fun and they're like
this girl is going to embarrass our
family we need to scoop out a part of
her brain yeah that's so there's the
kennedys for you
we went through the top of the head dr
watts recalled i think she was awake she
had a mild tranquilizer i made a
surgical incision in the brain through
the skull it was near the front it was
on both sides we just made a small
incision no more than an inch the
instrument dr watts used looked like a
butter knife oh my god hung it up and
cut down to the brain tissue we put an
instrument inside
and he asked to recite lord's prayer or
sing god bless america or count
backwards we made an estimate on how far
to cut based on how she responded dude
that is so cool
so so they said okay once she can no
longer
um
verb speak then then we're good we're
we're basically turning her into a
vegetable
dude
and no offense to vegetables
why was she cooperating no offense to
the incapacitated dude that's [ __ ]
crazy i don't think she had a choice
also they probably lied to her just like
this is just a little something to help
with your mood swing sweetie and then
they took a [ __ ] ice cream scooper to
her brain bro oh my god dude i can't
believe that was like a medical thing
that people were doing
like that's wild yeah it's it's it's
really disturbing god damn dude well you
know and one flew over the cuckoo's nest
that was a very uh accurate depiction of
the time of what they did they [ __ ]
lobotomized and then they
institutionalized their after
yeah because well she's in she's
she's a vegetable yeah she's basically
like brain dead
um
it's so disturbing like how they had her
talking and then once
it quickly became apparent that the
procedure had not been successful
kennedy's mental capacity diminished to
that of a two-year-old child she could
not walk or speak intelligibly and was
incontinent awesome good job guys great
father of the decade
jesus christ dude that's yeah so they're
i mean so that's the fam the kennedy
family those are the the darlings of the
liberal or whatever i don't know but
they're all demons you're probably
triggering cam so hard right now by the
way because he's from boston yeah
sorry cam is are you okay
i think i'll make it
okay
yeah that's one of the worst things i've
ever heard yeah i just i
i'm speechless on this
this is not
uh
normally i would you know come in quick
and be like some people deserve to get
lobotomized actually like if you're
[ __ ] one of my haters on the internet
you probably need one of these
procedures but like even i i'm shocked i
can't even say that right now jfk got
lobotomized eventually too right
oh that's [ __ ] up technically yeah
that's funny yeah this procedure
definitely didn't work though like that
one actually the only difference between
jfk's lobotomy and um his sisters is his
was a little more uh precise yeah oh my
god yeah she by the way
rosemary died
in 2005 at the age of 86 so she just
lived like that for so many additional
years wow that's crazy where's jfk's
lobotomy instant yeah out of his pain
immediately yeah boom done
one and done she probably wished she got
jfk's lobotomy after
living that long i don't know i mean
dude that's so that's just like i don't
even know at that point it's like so
torturous that like is it even torture
do you even recognize who knows
you've probably successfully killed
someone
there's got to be some level of
awareness that
she used to be normal i i don't want to
think about it yeah no jesus christ dude
holy [ __ ] we are so
god damn dude we are so
nasty and gross like human beings are
just so awful well back in the day that
was a treat oh an accepted treatment for
for homosexuality was it a lobotomy or
castration chemical castration uh
the uk chemically incarcerated alan
turing
famously
yes he killed himself but that so so for
me that kind of
tells you all you need to know about
like the transphobia now today you know
uh gay people have been fighting for
their rights now for decades and just
recently it's become
somewhat accepted obviously still a
bunch of loathing from the conservatives
like ben shapiro and his manlet crew
but what you're seeing is back in the
50s and 60s people [ __ ] despised
homosexuals they thought it was mental
illness they were lobotomizing them
castrating them and that's what you see
with trans gender people today it's the
same [ __ ] thing it's so obvious yeah
and it's the same conservatives now
we're like if these people are mentally
ill this is child abuse whatever
whatever it's the same [ __ ] rhetoric
they used in the 50s and 60s that we all
now look back with the numbers honestly
right you're right you're right yeah the
homophobia stuff is just like
it was uh
it was it was popping like in the 90s
even very true only only like
only in the aftermath i would say of the
obergefell decision did it become like
kind of normalized for a little bit
that's when you started seeing like you
know uh cis white gays be like i'm a
republican actually you know shouts out
to dave rubin i love that like i'm a log
cabin republican i'm just like a
straight republican republican you know
um and then now
the conservative movement is like
rushing to immediately roll that back
because if you take your foot off the
gas because we take progress for granted
we always think and i i myself included
i'm in this uh no matter how pessimistic
i am i still think that progress is
inevitable right i think no matter what
happens like the next generation is
going to be a little bit more socially
conscious at least you know
and that's not the case because the
reactionary movement is never sleeping
they are constantly looking for any
avenue they can to continue increasing
the dial of brutality on marginalized
people and the moment that you take your
foot off the gas on the progressive side
the moment that you stop defending a
particular marginalized group because
you think all right we've established
you know
we have established some civil liberties
for this group here and they can now be
like a normal part of society and seen
as like normal people
boom they're like nope we're back we're
back to it yeah you're right they took
the
uh homophobic takes about like gay
people being pedophiles gay people being
groomers
being like morally degenerate and and
just copy pasted it to trans people in
the exact same fashion and now
you're watching them roll that back with
like the don't say gay bill basically
[ __ ] stating that like uh any kind of
mention of a gay couple in in
you know in the media is actually just
grooming you're like grooming people
which is so crazy for so like first of
all
i mean the people who are really
grooming kids are
at your [ __ ] sunday school every week
i mean let's be real about who's
grooming well where the thread is at
i'm just being real here the way they
use grooming is also so stupid because
it's like they think education is
grooming and i guess yeah if you want to
like expand on the definition of
grooming away from like uh you know
grooming someone to engage in sexual
acts at an early age in a coercive
capacity
then yeah that's what they're using is
grooming and so is like you said sunday
school and now no no no that's not i
didn't mean sunday school i meant
there's people there who literally want
to [ __ ] your kids that too yeah of
course of course you missed my meeting
on child marriage is like you know we
got warren jeff defenders like tucker
carlson out there running around saying
like child marriage is actually
different than like uh you know child
rape because it's a lifetime commitment
you know what i mean like he literally
says that's awesome he has said that
like i'm not making this up life's a i'm
a lifetime commitment
yeah but anyway so so let's get into the
ben shapiro daily wire so ben shapiro
first of all talking about like modern
day homophobia he is losing his [ __ ]
[ __ ]
over a new disney pixar film called
light year
this movie was banned in 14 countries
including saudi arabia uae
malaysia because there's a same sex kiss
now if people tell you pride month is
stupid and we don't need it let me read
that again 14 countries banned this film
for a same-sex kiss saudi arabia uae and
malaysia
turns out disney did actually remove the
kiss initially
but it was only re-added once there was
an open letter from pixar employees
demanding it be reinstated to the film
so
get this tape can i read can i read it
in bench bureau yeah yeah yeah please
disney works to push a not at all secret
gay agenda and seeks to add queerness to
its programming according to executive
producer latoya ravenou
parents should keep that in mind before
deciding whether to take their kids to
see light year which hits theaters this
week
children are not adults what may be
appropriate for adults is not
appropriate for children that this must
be said demonstrates that our society is
in a state of moral collapse so yeah
dude when i see a pregnant woman in a
[ __ ] like you know in in like
rugrats or whatever i'm immediately like
well what the [ __ ] that means sex
happened actually we need to stop that i
just don't i don't understand this
conspiracy that it's a secret it's a gay
agenda it's literally just
one kiss
what what the [ __ ] are you talk what is
this secret gay agenda to make
to
to show real people doing real things
like i'm sorry to tell you there are gay
people in the world ben yeah um what is
the agenda though yeah the entire point
of it is like well here's the thing
um
conservatives want to groom their
children both literally in the way that
you mentioned like they want to they
want to [ __ ] them do the yeah do the
child grooming rapes they want to [ __ ]
the kids they do 100 percent um shout
out to lauren borbert who was 17 when
she started dating her sex offender
husband um so
they want to do that but they also want
to
groom their children into believing that
like gay people don't exist in society
so that it is very deeply uh
uncomfortable for a gay person to
recognize that they're queer right like
a queer person recognizes their queer or
come out
um
out of the fear that like uh they will
be cast aside
uh and and considered morally degenerate
so that's the main reason why they don't
want this to happen they don't even want
people to recognize that the you know
there are gay people in society so they
can keep up the lie for as long as they
can
and it actually harms people
demonstrably uh bench bureau routinely
brings up the trevor project numbers uh
basically a hotline that works with uh
lgbt teens that are
uh you know at the verge of suicide or
have tried to commit suicide like uh and
and he thinks that it's a it's a
horrible place i love that the horrible
uh you know philanthropic
his take is just let him kill themselves
guys yeah no he's
that's awesome lead with love
lead with love just like jesus well
bench bear is a jew but you know uh
he leads with love
and
basically that's what it is they think
that like even if you mention or even if
you show like a gay couple
in a tv show
that means you're you know you're you're
grooming children because like they're
gonna see that and be like oh i'm gay
now that's what they think that's the
fear right but that's what i mean but
that's a self-report like that means
you're gay that means that you [ __ ]
get that like thank you that means when
you see gay people you get turned on and
you're scared you go oh [ __ ] i'm getting
tempted tempted because this [ __ ] looks
dope and there's nothing and there's
nothing wrong with that so they like
one of the main arguments always is like
pointing to
the rate of like uh people recognizing
that they're lgbt like and how much
higher that number is oh yeah they think
the whole society is turning gay and
they say yeah exactly
they keep saying like the society's
turning gay but that's not the case and
there are similar examples of this
throughout history the one i always
point to is the left-handedness uh chart
yeah it's not like there's something in
the water that made people left-handed
it's just that people stopped forcing
uh you know people stopped forcing you
to use your right hand
he thought that this was insane and
outdated so then it [ __ ] skyrocketed
yeah there's about 12
of the population is left-handed back in
the 1900s they wouldn't they wouldn't
they were trying to make everyone
right-handed because they thought being
left-handed was
not right yeah whatever mark of the
devil and so once people stop giving you
social pressures to be right-handed then
the natural rate comes back up to 12
it's the same thing with homosexuality
same with children with autism probably
the same with
transgenderism yeah a more reasonable
example of it is is autism right like
famously you know uh disgraced former
doctor andrew wakefield
came up with the idea that vaccines
cause autism
and that's why they should use his
vaccine instead that's a longer story
i'm not going to get into it but uh that
really gained prominence that conspiracy
theory you really gained prominence and
that's why people were saying like well
the autism rates are skyrocketing
currently well no it's because medical
diagnosis improved yes so we now know
how many more people are actually on the
spectrum and uh that doesn't mean that
like something in the food is causing
people to get autism or some [ __ ] it's
just that we have better tools to figure
out uh you know
when someone is on the spectrum or not
um can we do it so stupid can we use
that idiotic they they use their idiocy
and the idiocy of their audience uh as a
way to really hammer in their their agit
prop it's [ __ ] up well and the
frustrating thing with these concepts is
like it's been explained to them 10 000
times it's self-explanatory it's
obviously the truth and then they they
keep ignoring the basic facts of the
matter
to promote their propaganda even though
it's been explained to them 10 000 times
and i'm sure they understand
uh but you know um
i just want to do a matt walsh mount
walsh fit check
what do we think about the glossy
bro on iron sure be honest
i hate the t-shirt
uh like it's so
so difficult to pull off
the t-shirt inside of your blazer look
yeah the blazer t-shirt combo is very
hard to pull off and matt walsh is not
pulling it off no okay i'm not a fan of
the glossy shirt and that exactly that's
that's a problem for me the the glossy
shirt like what are you wearing dry fit
bro is that under armour like what's
going on it's just so wrinkly here like
what happened down there bro it's just
it's just a devastatingly bad fit so
that that's matt walsh at the premiere
of their new movie
uh this is a movie
is that his wife
um i'm assuming so but i don't know for
sure he's like i mean he matt walsh i
mean he's not an unfaithful jebediah
i'll tell you that much he's not going
to be he's not going to be prancing
around with another harlot
oh no no no oh and then of course a-list
celebrities
at the premiere of these of their
now this is the premiere of their
who
this is rob schneider of course
wait what the [ __ ] why is what is he
actually at the what well he yeah he's
at the premiere for daley wires new
movie he's actually he is a total [ __ ]
bag i don't know if you knew that about
it i did not know that rob schneider
schneider not only is he not funny he's
actually a giant piece of [ __ ] yeah wait
deuce bigelow dude
he sucks dude he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i had no i mean i've never been
like a
you don't follow his career yes the boys
are gonna get really upset at the rob
schneider head fan meet up don't worry i
mean you're not the only one that
doesn't follow his career closely
wait till they hear about what rob has
been up to
oh no dude not the not the talented
egot award-winning
[ __ ] actor known for
being a stapler
from ethan's favorite show real rob
yeah that's one of the worst shows ever
made i recommend it he tried to make a
curvier enthusiasm ask show for netflix
that is the worst show i've ever seen
and it's just bizarre like the whole
show has a blue tint over it to make his
eyes look more blue i swear to god it's
just the whole thing and it's just so
bad it's so dumb yeah why why why try to
make someone as hot as rob schneider
even hotter like well because he he's
very insecure he's married to a young
beautiful uh wife he has in real life
it's his real wife who's who's in the
show and i think he oh a tweet from five
hours ago from rob schneider
yeah
he goes 2024 president desantis gets get
start getting used to it so dude i i i
want my sanchez this is so fast this is
great yeah no he's a piece of [ __ ] he is
it's interesting right rob schneider
rob schneider as a raging homophobe dude
that's sick that's fire
wow
now that makes sense it makes further
sense he's just not funny yeah his
twitter is all dog [ __ ] totally your
career it does say a lot about how
[ __ ] hard you fell off that like
you were you know like a relatively
pretty famous actor
comedic actor i use the term loosely uh
in the 90s and like early 2000s and like
people don't even know that you've
turned into a hog yeah yeah like people
chris pratt is popping right so when
when he even says anything about like
loving jesus everyone's like wait a
minute is he is he also homophobic
because like he's popping yeah rob
schneider not pop no no one cares no
well the movie i'm leading towards is
matt walsh's huge hit documentary what
is a woman
which was created with the express
purpose of
creating more transphobia in the world
the documentary features walsh asking
what is a woman and related questions to
a variety of people including a
pediatrician
a gender affirming family and a marriage
therapist a sex reassignment surgeon
transgender
opponent of medical transition for
minors and of course jordan peterson
makes an appearance
it's just like it's so funny when these
guys are constantly like complaining
about how liberalism like go woke go
broke is like
ruining culture and like ruining
hollywood and there is some truth to
that i do think that like you know you
should let movies have like bad
characters and exhibit bad behavior as
long as a good [ __ ] movie like i
don't give a [ __ ] you know what i mean
just don't take my movies away
right
um and like the aesthetic pandering that
you see in a lot of like hollywood
movies is like very transparent and i
think people are waking up to that
reality as well especially because it
like doesn't do anything to offer like
it doesn't offer any like material
restitution right and it's just simply
aesthetic pandering right
um
however
conservatives then flip the narrative
and do this
at least like
you know hollywood makes an effort to be
like more diverse and put more diverse
cast members on and representation is
still important right but ultimately the
storylines are not all about like being
woke or whatever so why are they doing
this you're doing an entire movie that
is just about being not woke about being
transphobic and it's not going to
[ __ ] work because
it's only going to work with people who
already are like sick twisted [ __ ]
freaks who who want this content they're
like yeah i can't stop thinking about
trans people all the time it makes me so
angry every now and then
they're not real women yeah every waking
moment in my existence is like being
angry at transfer
sorry not beautiful yeah yeah
and and so like yeah this is for those
freaks and it's for like a lot of people
who then will watch this and get mad at
it a lot of people i hate to say it but
there's a lot of [ __ ] people that are
down with this [ __ ] like a lot
anyway here's a clip from his film
which is pretty funny he includes this
conversation where he thinks he got the
dub but he actually looks like an idiot
stephen crowder's style
uh here it is but this is kind of the
craziness that is happening right now
where
he's obviously getting owned
but he thought he looked good and but it
doesn't matter because just like you
correctly pointed out
rigid gender norms are so deeply
embedded in our existence and it's
something that like a lot of humans
hold very near and dear to themselves
and their entire world view is
constructed around them so there's a lot
of people who either never think about
this look it's not an attack on
anybody's gender it's just simply
no but but people don't think about it
right they think male female that's it
everything else seems kind of weird kind
of strange don't understand it don't
want to think about it and a lot of
people either go okay i don't really
give a [ __ ] whatever let people live but
then there's also people who are like no
actually this is like hitting me in the
face and i hate that they have a slant
towards bigotry so when they see stuff
like this it reinforces their biases
and uh and and something that i always
used to say like
back in back when like donald trump was
trying to make an argument about like
how obama flubbed the swine flu uh he
would always use this false equivalency
he would say obama failed with swine flu
more than i failed with covid and he
would bring up the numbers but if you
look at the numbers actually obama
[ __ ] killed way less people with the
swine flu than trump did with covid
right dude there's a gillion examples of
that yeah but that's that's a false
equivalence that like someone on the
other side the opposing side would use
against donald trump normally but
because of how stupid the audience
members are because of how stupid his
base is and how stupid we are in general
they they don't care it's just the
virtue of trump by the verge of trump
saying it they agree with him even if
it's a false equivalence even if the
facts are actually not on his side and
that's precisely what's going on here
because the people are already like
predispositioned to be transphobic
because of societal norms and and how
they've uh you know how they've
developed
uh they see someone make dumb arguments
like this and just keep saying what is a
woman what is a woman like a like a
[ __ ] five-year-old that's what
happened asking why why why why why why
why until you have no answer for it um
yeah that's right and they think it
doesn't matter it's good but yeah but
the thing the thing that annoys me about
this i'm going to play in a second guys
i promise but the thing that annoys me
is he goes
it's like they pretend that the
difference between
gender and sex hasn't been explained to
them in the simplest terms 10 000 times
they just can't fathom that they act
like they never heard of this thing
before and they create all these
documentaries just ignoring the simplest
fact that gender
and sex can be separable here is matt
walsh getting owned what we do in in
gender studies is not just reduce gender
to what psychologists might call
individual differences but rather
thinking about gender and that's not
women and man but gender as a as a
social form something that kind of
infuses itself into virtually all
aspects of social life
let's talk about that then
uh got him i guess we should start with
we've got gender and sex
right
what what's the difference between the
two is there a difference i saw that in
your questions and i thought my goodness
this is what we spend an entire semester
kind of thinking through but what we
tend to think about in the social
sciences today
is that sex refers to a set of
biological characteristics
and gender is a social construct or
category
what i think is often misleading about
that characterization is allowed to be
serious pause it for a
this is the most [ __ ] up part like he
was actually giving a really thoughtful
dude interesting explanation this [ __ ]
pissed me off bro like he he literally
goes up
takes time out of this dude's day to
just [ __ ]
and then he just cuts it like he just
cut his [ __ ] descriptions does he
know it owns him there is no better
example there is no better example that
like you are just in bad faith not
trying to actually uh understand
anything and instead trying to craft a
compelling narrative in the opposing
direction then exactly what he did he's
basically like uh
he's gonna take these dudes he's like
and anyway i blacked out for ten minutes
like when he was actually giving me a
good explanation that's why you got to
keep her cool and just be like what's up
why are you asking is it because you're
is it because you're sexless is that
what it is yeah they'll use that against
you too
they will but like there's nothing
there's no
they revel in bad faith it doesn't
matter what real world
you can actually have a conversation
with some people are really too far down
the pipeline
uh to legitimately have a conversation
with when they become like debate
perverts on this issue that means they
like sought out these uh this
information that that reinforces their
pre-existing biases right that's going
to be really difficult but a lot of
people are just genuine a lot of people
are just confused and you can have a
conversation with them i try to do this
all the time on my stream as well um and
and you know they might even pop off
with like a microaggression here and
there but as long as you are genuine in
your interest in learning and changing
your attitude and changing your mind
i'm i'm with you i'm with you all the
way i will explain it to you i'll sit
down and explain to you but professional
conservatives like matt walsh are not in
that category no you will never be able
to convince them otherwise because they
make money
doing this they make money and gain
clout and fame and notoriety by cutting
these kinds of videos they're not there
to learn and as a matter of fact god
forbid someone accidentally learned
something from this [ __ ] video that's
why he cut the just exactly
the guy was doing great he was doing
great and he yada yada him but let's see
where it goes from here and when you
split them up into these holy discrete
constructs studies scholars and he's
basically like and then he started
getting on with all the [ __ ] yeah
but actually how about you just let the
people list like it's so gross this is
incredible [ __ ] gross this is
storytelling my friend this is high
level documentarianism right here
dude what the [ __ ] he's actually really
smart and thoughtful right yeah why go
to a professor and ask him a question
if you're going to
yadda him
so here's what it's not here's what
you're supposed to do in a situation
like this like if you're going to deal
with a professional conservative or one
that's like operating like one of these
professional conservatives like larping
like them on the internet what you have
to do is learn all their talking points
if first of all i would suggest you not
engage because you're not actually gonna
you know it's not gonna be a productive
conversation you're not gonna be able to
change their minds for the most part
but
um if you are engaging with someone who
is at least armed with some of the
talking points of a professional
conservative like this you need to learn
the talking points and figure out the
most effective counters are well he did
and then they cut him that's what's
[ __ ] up he didn't he actually gave a
long who knows what he said they cut his
ass i know but he gave a long thoughtful
academic answer you need to do one-hit
liners like
when when someone when i i don't know
what's the difference between gender and
sex you have to have like a quick
marketable uh think tank back top i
think that's how they operate i think
that's one angle that's good for someone
like you but this man he takes what he
does seriously and
matt walsh sought him out an academic
for an academic answer and he's trying
and what he's being abused for his yeah
he thought that this was a
he thought that this was going to be a
instance where he's like having a
conversation with someone who is coming
at it and maybe in good faith like
yeah maybe he had an opportunity to
change his mind it's it's hubris but
anyway he still owns him let's watch the
clip
really more specifically people who
study gender and sex we're not talking
about sexuality right and the kind of
academic universe that i travel in is
that we see how deeply gendered ideas um
cultural ideas about
feminism
and femaleness both in humans and in
lots of other animals
so are gender insects two different
things or
well i think that owned baby he might as
well he might as well have just been
like i'm sorry i wasn't listening
yeah
just say yes
i'm comfortable saying that gender and
sex are two different constructs but
they're deeply intertwined with each
other we're talking about gender and sex
and there's a lot of controversies there
if we're talking about what are the
controversies there
there's no controversies there with
gender and sex you're talking about
gender studies professor like what is
the controversy dumbass this is his
entire [ __ ] life is like describing
these concepts also they there's this
implication that like this guy's wasting
his life on this dumb [ __ ] it's like
don't you think gender even outside your
bigotry is an interesting social science
like to study that no because
yeah i mean well
technically he's doing that too but just
in the reverse but he doesn't recognize
that he's doing that in the reverse he's
you're doing gender studies bro yeah
you're a gender studies professor
matt walsh the funniest thing is that is
actually like a very weirdly fascinating
phenomena where like ben shapiro and
matt walsh know
way more about trans issues
than like the average person does they
think about trans people more than trans
people do you know what i mean like
they're literally just like every day
every waking moment they're like
how can i find a different way to [ __ ]
on trans people so like they have to
study up on all the [ __ ] trans [ __ ]
that's going on they like pay attention
to the latest in in medical technology
and [ __ ] just so they can find a new way
to dunk on trans people
has all of the male
physical characteristics so would that
not be
a male then couldn't we plainly say did
you just [ __ ] hear what he said you
dumb ass [ __ ] yes there's a
yes the sex is male
this person is a myth he's like bro i
just talked to you for an hour why are
you asking me this now well well i guess
it's like
why are you asking the question i think
i i want to understand sort of why
that's so important so basically what
happened is
he he they had a thoughtful conversation
for an hour
and now he's going back to this absurd
question and he's forcing him to get a
little irritated with how
purposely obtuse he's being and now
they're trying to include this to show
that he's like triggered or something
tells us
sort of understand
reality
you know
well i mean i understand who they are
you should believe them so if a person
says that they're a woman or they're a
man
then that's them telling you their
gender is i'm not so sure why what
social
um
interaction you know he's just being a
dick right and this guy's getting a
little you know no he's doing the so
vegans have this uh argument uh down to
a t where they do name the trait right
like it's a it's basically uh an
impossible argument to get out of
where like vegans morally uh on the on
the right side understandably i i you
know i'm with you even though i eat a
lot of chicken um but they always do the
name the trade argument right where
they'll just go
and say like okay uh
name an a a single
like diagnosable trait within humans
that's like different than an animal and
it's like you're basically trapping
someone then you can eat a comatose
person like you know what i mean that's
i don't know if you've ever heard this
argument before or not but this is very
common so
it's like a trick it's a rhetorical
trick that you can apply in a debate and
that's what's going on right now this is
a hostile debate he might not recognize
it but that is precisely what's
happening here so in order to defeat him
in the marketplace of ideas what this
gender studies professor should have
done is basically revert back to the
name the trade argument to be like
you're asking me what a woman is i've
already described it to you so now tell
me what what you think a woman is define
a trait that makes a woman a woman and
tell me how uh you operate in the real
world with that definition because
ultimately
um there are plenty of passing is not
the end-all be-all of being a woman or a
man obviously or being trans but there
are
so many passing uh
trans people for example that you would
never
uh
you would never
turn and misgender
because no one else in the room would
understand that you're like actually
referring to that person uh i use a
buck angel as an example regularly once
again controversial figure certainly but
like this is a good entry point into
um this is a good entry point into the
the conversation uh usually with
transphobes is to bring up buck angel
like a man that looks like a burly biker
guy
but is a trans man right you would never
point to someone like buck angel if you
have a photo we can pull it up and go
hey can you in a crowded room you would
never point to buck angel and go can you
get my bag from that woman over there
and point the buck angel
like if you were to say can you get my
bag from that woman over there
right and point it to this dude no one
would understand you
like everyone would say what the [ __ ]
are you talking about
right and that is i think a perfect uh
way to describe how gender is and gender
expression is
basically an ongoing uh and socially
conditioned thing that we all
abide by
do you see what i'm saying yeah totally
and people would look at you like you're
a crazy person if you pointed to that
dude and said that woman over there has
my bag
no one would understand that
no one 100
it's it's it's it's yeah exactly
but the thing is you know these
these conversations could have taken
place but we know matt walsh edited the
[ __ ] out of this by simply just
doing like a time lapse over his
talking this would have to do with with
maleness or femaleness that we've i'm
not even talking about social context
i'm just i'm just trying to start by
getting to the truth you know
yeah i mean i'm really uncomfortable
with that language of like getting to
the truth again in social life why is
that uncomfortable because that sounds
actually deeply transphobic to me yes it
is and if you keep probing it it is
transphobic that's why it feels that way
we're going to because he's assuming so
first of all he is doing the
conservative thing where it's like well
there's no uh moral or cultural
relativism and that like there's only
one true nature right and and
the irony of course is that you could
revert that argument back to him and
immediately be like nature is gay as
[ __ ] nature is trans as [ __ ] if you want
to think about it from like an
anthropomorphized perspective
and also on top of that like there's
intersex people that exist you know what
i mean millions of intersex people exist
uh on this planet uh
and that like if you want to even talk
about like the biological aspect of sex
sex
before we think about like gender which
is a social expression that you add on
top of your sex right
um there's plenty of instances even in
nature that completely abolish your
perspective they completely destroy your
perspective
um and that's you gotta you just gotta
immediately flip it back on them like
the the notion that like you think there
is a truth here uh when uh the the
scientific community's consensus on
biology or what you would consider
biological gender or sex is not even
a long uh is not even actually aligned
with your uh reactionary point of view
it's not it is demonstrably false he is
spreading a demonstrable falsehood and
no [ __ ] by uh no biology professor no
actual scientist would ever agree with
matt walsh's definition with the
exception of like the edge cases that
are psychotic like the anti-vaxx doctors
and [ __ ] you know what i mean
yeah i mean it's just kind of sad
because i actually feel bad for this guy
because he thought he was having a good
faith debate and then
and then matt walsh just leaves being
blatantly
offensive and homophobic or transphobic
and uh then he gets he's like yo dude
what the [ __ ] is this
and then matt walsh is just like i'm
just asking questions why are you so
triggered yeah he's i [ __ ] hate this
guy so much i if i probe about what the
truth is you keep invoking the word
truth which is condescending and rude
yes i'm saying to you how is the word
truth condescending you know what you're
doing you little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you
know exactly he just explained all this
[ __ ] to you you dumb goofy ass [ __ ] mike
this dude's entire look at this it's
like smug rage comic meme right there oh
well how is it being offensive
yeah no he's like i owned you i owned
you meanwhile like he gets offended at
the existence of trans people so
meanwhile he's like how did i offend you
there was a kid there was like two
ladies kissed in disney yeah
shut it down
yeah but that's not [ __ ] cool
it's like the worst part
of the loser ass [ __ ] you if i ever see
you matt walsh i'm gonna i gouge your
glasses no you're not yeah no i will
you're gonna you're gonna give him a
little kissy poo no i'm not gonna hurt
him i'm not going to hurt him
and i just i think it's funny you know
no ethan they're going to [ __ ] be
like ethan is being violent do it let me
explain what i'm threatening okay
it's rewind time
no no it's not
it's funny when you try to eye gouge
someone with glasses because you can't
do it as as a member of the four eyes
community i take offense to what you say
so i'm gonna do that to him you're
talking like a uh three stooges style
yes yes yes he doesn't need to do that
because he's exactly got the glass can i
try it on you just to show what i'm
talking about you can you can eye gouge
me if you want here i'll put my hand up
too
[Music]
i feel attacked
that's what i did i didn't i didn't
actually do your glass yeah because it
does look nice right um so well
going back to the main point about matt
walsh though is that like he is a
hysterical person
like these guys are [ __ ] frothing out
of the mouth
all the goddamn time over like some of
the most innocuous [ __ ] okay trans
people existing in society seeing like a
lesbian couple in a disney movie like
they froth out of the mouth when they
see that they get a [ __ ] aneurysm
when they when they even think about
like a gay couple or even in some
instances an interracial couple existing
right um
so then them turning around and like
finding ways to prod and like really
frustrate people and then be like why
are you frustrated it's so stupid you're
a silly [ __ ] your entire existence is
like being triggered all the [ __ ]
time yes [ __ ] up it it's so true am i
gonna get in trouble am i gonna get
another strike
i think we may have saved it with the
goofiness of the that's what i'm saying
it's first of all it's not a serious
threat
it's just a goof on the three stooges
thing okay
watch there watch the clip the 10 second
clip yeah i'm gonna eye gouge matt walsh
yeah no they'll they'll [ __ ] cry
there's the clip right there
literally matt walsh would literally
argue for like the the genocide of trans
people and then turn around and be like
i can't believe you said yeah honestly
it's like first of all you are literally
promoting violence right now let's be
clear what you're doing is violence and
it's successful violence that's the
difference it's like violence backed by
the state that is aligned with the
normative position that is transphobic
so of course no one considers that to be
actually violent uh behavior when you
are advocating for when you're
advocating for insane controls on what
women can and can't do on their own
bodies form of like abortion control
that's violence on women definitely
thousands of women that are going to die
force
violence yeah the medical because they
can't get a [ __ ] medically induced
abortion like they can't do that so now
they're gonna [ __ ] die thanks that's
violence but no one sees it as such
because it is violence that is cowardly
because it's backed by the [ __ ] state
and it's aligned with the hegemonic
structures that's cowardly to just like
hide behind the state and be like oh i
hope the big bad state hurts the women
that wronged me by stopping uh the
people from having sex when they want to
consensually because like i just don't
want that to happen
i want everyone to be in a trad cath
lifestyle like what i think is the
appropriate way like [ __ ] you you're a
piece of [ __ ] you're not even [ __ ]
brave enough to shut up come out and be
like yeah i don't think i don't think
women should uh have sex and and that's
why i want to punish them you just want
to [ __ ] hide behind the state big
daddy state always same with this trans
same with this uh anti-trans [ __ ] always
except he's not even hiding it he openly
stated that like no one under no
condition whatsoever in whatever age
group should be able to get uh hrt he
said that the other day which is you
know that's it you're openly stating
that people should not get a medical
procedure that is demonstrably good they
go well they go you know uh
teens and young adults who transition
are
far less likely to unalive themselves or
do self-harm he's like [ __ ] that yeah
make it illegal that's violence
anyway let's continue because this is
good but look at smug matt walsh
why don't you tell me what your truth is
and you're walking on 30 seconds more of
the nights before i get up
what my truth is well i don't think i
really have the truth i think that
there's just
the truth
like the reality
and so
we should begin by trying to figure out
what the reality is
uh-huh and why are you concerned with
when someone else tells you that they're
a man
or even if they use the word male why
are you concerned with not believing
them
well you keep bringing it back to you
know how do you respond in a social
situation that's what i do but that's
what gender is like
that's what gender is that's what gender
is no that's what gender is that's what
gender is let's let it roll because he
actually owns him here he's so stupid
why do you keep going back to the social
context of a social science yeah but i'm
literally a professor
of social science like there is no
you don't [ __ ] run around and like
literally demand to know demand to get
blood work so you can see the t levels
of every single person that you're
[ __ ] interacting with to see what
their chromosomes are and then like put
intersex people in a separate category
if that's the case too because there's a
a whole different can of worms in that
on that field as well but like you don't
do that you just look at someone and if
they tell you they're a woman you're
like okay this is a woman that's what
normal people are supposed to do when
you told me your name is ethan klein i
didn't go no [ __ ] your name is
not ethan klein your name is actually
ben i decided again and i kept calling
you ben
he's ignoring the fact that sex you can
see gender you can't see there you go
simple as that it's been explained a
gazillion times
and he's just ignoring that concept
situation that's what i do i'm a social
scientist well right but we're in a
university this is a place of
understanding truth isn't it or i'm
getting so excited i'm getting so mad
hold on we gotta watch this we gotta
we're never gonna get it it's literally
like going up to a [ __ ] quantum
physicist and being like what you are
studying i don't believe in explain it
to me and then going around and being
like well i still don't believe it
actually well it's so stupid he goes
it's not the truth it's like truth is
subjective universities are place of
thoughts and experiments and exploration
so this whole notion is like no the
truth is the truth it's like bro come on
the truth is it's always subjective you
dumb goofy [ __ ]
nerd ass [ __ ] like yeah exactly uh and
it is ridiculous even if
there is
not an objectivist the person he's
talking to is not an objectivist and
neither is matt bosh by the way these
[ __ ] conservatives love being uh love
talking like a post-modernist whenever
it comes to like deconstructing certain
realities uh all the [ __ ] time but
um but but they're not you're asking
someone who has a fundamentally
different philosophy than you do in a
different worldview than you do who is
an expert in his own [ __ ] field about
their field and then trying to own them
by being like well i know less than you
in this regard and i disagree with you
but because so many [ __ ] people are
that stupid they go oh yeah he actually
did do a great job here matt walsh did
present himself very well look how
triggered this like libtard tardis like
he was a dick to him that was awesome
yeah but um
i think the whole truth thing is
basically it's all back to religion
right and all these guys are super
religious so
anyone who comes out like the truth is
the truth it's like the truth is god
made the universe and we're all [ __ ]
god's
creation it's like okay that's the truth
you're talking about god god hates trans
people and he cr he make that was a
mistake trans people was a mistake
everything else is unfollowed in fact
is infallible though except trans people
that was his one mistake the truth and
i'm a social scientist and that's what i
do you just said the truth is
transphobic
that you would say that you're if you're
saying the truth is that i get to say
you're not a man show me your genitalia
that's transphobic no i don't want to
see him as genitalia i i just mean no
yeah someone can make a statement about
themselves that could be untrue like for
example if i
if i were to say that i'm a black man
bro sex gender sex and gender
[ __ ] own dude but i love i love how
he's like if i said a black man that's
obviously not true to you it's like well
let me see your [ __ ] 23andme [ __ ] no
you know what i love about that actually
um one of my favorite things that
[ __ ] conservatives do all the time is
like they constantly claim that there is
this phantom trans person that is going
to like secretly not be trans but then
fake like they're actually trans right
they always say that this is a very real
threat that's like oh like the bathroom
hysteria yeah like the bathroom hysteria
is one where he's like well someone
could say that they're trans just to go
into the women's room and then do a rape
it's like that's illegal that's separate
you can't just like [ __ ] what do you
think like that it's like it gives you a
a barrier of protection when you say
you're a trans person like it doesn't
work that way and that person could
[ __ ] lie and say that they're a trans
person it doesn't [ __ ] matter or they
could just go in the bathroom and do it
yeah exactly what they do like no no
rapist is like i was gonna violate the
law for rape but then i saw that [ __ ]
thing that says women only and i was
like well i guess i can't do it today
yeah [ __ ] i'm pretty sure it doesn't
matter what there that's insane looking
like because they can't find people that
are faking being trans
they will then become the person that's
faking being trans like stephen
or [ __ ] that that other like dude who
did the deadlift challenge like zoobee
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is like
they always do this they can't they
create this like evil being
they can't find that evil being in the
wild so then they become that person
he's literally just saying well what if
i lie and tell you i'm a woman right
there's actually he's done this three
different times i mean yeah i mean
listen cross-dressing is practically a
a hobby for crowder at this no i think
it's a way of life
i often say i often say drag is simply
an expression and it's not necessarily
like a part of your sexuality even
though it is like uh it is it can be
sexual in nature and it cannot be sexual
energy it's a performance but for
stephen crowder i do think it's a way of
his life i i do think it goes way beyond
the performance for him he's committed
or
you know whatever his drag name would be
her but um would be the problem with her
her in drag
so again but i go back to this point and
it's so basic like again you're just
ignoring that sex and gender are
separate that's all you do that's all
they always do
and they act so smug about it it's like
my sex
is male
yeah my gender can be whatever the [ __ ]
i want it to be it's so obvious no i
don't want to see him as genitalia i i
just mean yeah he does someone can make
a statement about themselves that could
be untrue this is the lie for example
this is the last time he says he doesn't
want to see genitalia he's lying why is
he lying when he says he doesn't want to
see genitalia because that's the only
way like in ohio where a new bill passed
in the ohio state legislature okay
shouts out to ohio trying to desperately
become the worst state in america good
job guys okay you're [ __ ] literally
worse than idaho think about that for a
second okay um go buckeyes
so in ohio they passed the measure where
like you could literally just say this
girl is trans or this entire team is
trans and then they have to undergo
medical procedures where a doctor needs
to look at their [ __ ] genitalia
genitalia like they have to touch their
[ __ ] and [ __ ] to figure out if these
young girls are [ __ ] like assigned
female at birth or not okay i'm sure
that uh
all the right people are gonna be
rushing into that position that's what
would be the genital checker
all of a sudden there's all these people
from the from the church uh signing up
to be genital checkers at the the school
gymnasium
how insane is that bro like you
literally in an effort to like what dunk
on the one trans girl that's like
potentially you know not even [ __ ]
owning uh in in like handball or
whatever the [ __ ] imagine the one person
they're like you look like a man young
lady yeah and then they check she's like
oh sorry about that yeah no that's
literally but that's it that's what's
going to end up happening and that is
the level of psychopathy that you need
to engage in in order to like justify
their horrific and psychotic world i
told you conservatives want to [ __ ] kids
straight up boom that's why he's like i
don't want to touch genitalia i don't
who said that who said that i want to
touch genitalia i've simply only
defended the duggar family uh on
multiple occasions that's because i want
to [ __ ] kids doesn't mean i want to
touch their genitalia yeah
yeah it's great let's watch let's watch
we have to we have to get through this
who
would you accept that or would you be
skeptical
well let's argue but it's so stupid
because you could have black heritage uh
in your genealogy it's like well if
you're gonna lie to people and tell them
you're black why should they question
that the premise he's presenting is
[ __ ] so dumb yeah like who would do
that you're like no i have so i'm i'm
part black uh they'd be like you [ __ ]
liar you scum
black are you afraid of american are you
racial
yeah exactly
you're not obviously not biracial that
is such a dumb point but he was like i'm
gonna lose my audience if they find out
that i'm biracial it's so [ __ ] funny
because this is such a dumb point he's
actually not smart in this in the
slightest he's a [ __ ] i think so okay
well you don't think that and i don't
think that's a that it doesn't sound
like that's a genuine statement of who
you are thank you
yes okay so that's my point i i could
make a statement about who i am that's
incorrect
of course i think it's well established
that human beings can lie yes
exactly i mean i could just be mistaken
okay so dude he is so dumb that he
thinks this is interesting you know you
can be mistaken yeah
uh
i guess this all comes back just this
all comes down to really one question
especially
women
gender and sexuality studies
so so what
what is a woman [ __ ] slammed bro
that dramatic pause let's hear
he this he's late this is it this is the
bombs about to drop let's hear it record
i just want to point out you can do this
five-year-olds do this all the time when
they ask you like why
why
why why oh yeah my son does it every
[ __ ] day [ __ ] answer because you
can't give the scientific basis of like
how the world began you know what i mean
like my son does that every day it's
like you're getting married and that's
normal you go uh uh what the rose is red
why is the rose red
uh probably because the light reflects
and it's a beautiful color to it why and
well insects are attracted to color
because there's pollen there why well
you know it's like [ __ ] now dude yeah
and after a certain point you like
arrive at you arrive at like this this
position where you're like i don't have
the answers for you man and and and
conservatives have taken that like
five-year-old genuine curiosity sure and
made it their only form of argumentation
which is [ __ ] insane okay and it
should show you how insanely stupid they
are but instead because we're all
[ __ ] stupid we think this is
brilliant well he's obviously the really
smart guy like looking at this and matt
walsh is a literal [ __ ] barely
literate buffoon ape
let's watch
why do you ask that question
thank you
i just really like to know
he's literally like a kid being like why
are you punching yourself why are you
punching yourself uh cause i just wanna
i just wanted to slam dunk you by the
way remember how remember how i yada
yada your
your scientific explanation
no i just want i just want to understand
why they don't want to be around me
that's why i want to know what is a
woman so that i can understand why they
avoid me all the time right so strange
very true i think the answer that
question is
well i'm asking that's why i came to a
college professor who
well he already explained it and you
[ __ ] literally jump cutted through
his explanation you dumb [ __ ]
thank you
this is your this is what you do
bro how i just
it's so infuriating
a lot of like this where you're not
answering i've got a lot of that so i
think it's interesting that you that you
say that some of the people you've
you've
interviewed have been i'm reluctant to
answer it and i think that has a lot to
do with the way the questions that
preceded it and the way that you've
conducted yourself in the interview how
have i conducted myself
how do you think you've conducted
yourself
you just really don't want to answer the
questions oh my god
it's so pathetic
so [ __ ] pathetic he's answered your
questions in good faith and you cut over
it you literally you literally cut over
him
and now you're being like you don't
answer my ques i mean this man is a
[ __ ] yeah uh well pathetic it's
juvenile no it's like it's like [ __ ]
idiocracy and
the only person the higher iq is like
considered to be a [ __ ] psycho and a
weirdo because everyone else is that
stupid and that's what the world we're
living by the way this is the great
documentary people are hailing this as
an incredible documentary they are
benship but i'm saying beefing that up
on the republican side i know i know but
people do think this is good like ben
shapiro who's this great conservative
thinker published this [ __ ] changed his
icon on twitter to what is a woman and
they are taking this seriously
going to look something out while you
yeah i i came today very willing and
enthusiastic about answering questions
about women's and gender sexuality
studies which is what i do you wanted to
answer questions about women's studies
and so shouldn't the
first
you want to know how [ __ ] not
relatable or not interesting this
[ __ ] dumbass documentary is dude
google trend search what is a woman
which is a universal search like it's
not exactly just this documentary versus
[ __ ] morbius and you will understand
that like no this documentary didn't
[ __ ] pop off okay well hold on
morbius was like the top meme in the
world just to be i know but it doesn't
matter ultimately like any other [ __ ]
actual movie a movie that flopped in the
[ __ ] box office is still
significantly more important and
significantly uh you know more in the
public consciousness than like some
random reactionary uh documentary that
is paywall that people can't even
[ __ ] see for the most part and the
reason why i mentioned that is because
it's sometimes we get trapped in our
echo chambers uh on the internet and we
think that like something is
overemphasized because no our enemies
our intellectual enemies are saying it
is i gotta disagree with you morbius is
the top name in the whole country okay
there's like every tweet and if you look
at the modern they're not that close off
this documentary is popular compared to
something else like uh
[ __ ] what's what's something that's
going on now that's like uh
i don't know but ultimately
um january 6 okay that's that's an
interesting comparison
what is a woman crushing january yeah
because the generation commission
[ __ ] is well first of all because no
one gives a [ __ ] about the generation it
had like 20 million viewers
on the first i don't um google trend
seems to indicate otherwise so wait
let's do a different one what's a movie
that just came out
that is like
okay i mean dude that's not even a thing
dude that is going to be insane yeah top
gun crushed it yeah of course it did
because they have millions of dollars
billions of dollars in marketing behind
it and also they are incredibly popular
works but i do want to disagree with you
to an extent i think this movie is more
popular i mean if you compare it to me
you know what i mean if you look at it
like that then it's going to [ __ ]
destroy me right like it probably is
yeah exactly
it does it destroys so there you go dude
[ __ ] absolutely dominated by ben
shapiro no i'll do my name do my name
obviously that is the case obviously of
course that is the case
well they were like pumping out but
they're they're making it seem like
they're oh my god my name is dead
can i point out that when i searched for
hassan
it said uh internet celebrity when i
search for ethan it says eli klein's
husband great oh my god that's true
search um do uh what is a woman compared
to um
uh the trevor project
i mean that's like again it's not what
is a woman is a universal remember it's
a universal question that people are
probably no no no
[Music]
well you can look up the movie
no what is a look at look at the
trending before it wasn't that nothing
was happening it's obvious in the recent
one that yeah no the spikes are related
to the [ __ ] documentary because
they're pumping out insane amounts of
[ __ ] ads for it
that will change the seo but that's why
you have to compare it to like actual
movies with also uh uh that will top gun
is here let me go to rotten tomatoes and
pick out like a mid-range like
everything everywhere all at once
okay okay that's i mean that one's
pretty popular i've heard a lot about it
but go ahead i mean that's like isn't it
everything everywhere all at once isn't
that what it is
everything everywhere
[Music]
all at once
is that right yeah
there you go buddy no no everything over
where all at once is actually way higher
no but in recent times well they're
they're pretty [ __ ] close yeah
because they've been pumping out
marketing and everything everywhere all
at once is like uh listen it's
i hate to break it to you but this is a
popular documentary i don't think it's
as popular as people presented
people are watching this [ __ ]
listen just go to short king
kindergarten okay and see what's popping
there okay there's a couple of kings in
the room and it ain't
[Music]
it ain't the uh
daily wire guys
all right
and we're ready i'm ready to throw down
on these [ __ ]
two short kings against meme
against a bunch of man don't put jfk in
there i'm gonna get canceled for that
one he's gotten enough dude he's he's
good enough all right we're almost done
with this and let's just let this man
dig his grave here the woman well it's
it for me it's it's actually a really
simple answer and that's a person who
identifies as a woman but what are they
identifying as as a woman
what is that
as a woman
do you know what a circular definition
is oh my god you're such a duck i do
it's sort of like
what you're doing right now or a woman
is a woman
because you're seeking what we would
call in my field of work an essentialist
definition of gender i think it sounds
like you would like me to give you a set
of
biological or cultural characteristics
that are associated with one gender or
the other i'm not seeking any type of
definition i'm just you are you've been
lying
[Music]
he gave you one at length in the
beginning yeah that he cut over which
you
cut into pieces this so this this is
what's going on the daily wire these are
like one of the most popular media
outlets on facebook consistently on
youtube they're super popular and and
this this is the kind of media that that
a lot of people are consuming
and it's [ __ ] um
it's idiocy like you said i mean it is
it just plain idiot my point was this
okay they're in they're like physically
incapable of cutting like entertaining
[ __ ] i watch all the stuff like
christian movies and stuff ironically
and it's fun in that regard but this one
doesn't even meet that metric because
it's just like purely rage bait right um
and they're basically doing exactly what
they criticize hollywood for doing but
in the worst ways possible they're not
even like doing a little bit of
diversity right or they're not doing
like a little bit of aesthetic
conservatism instead they're just making
an entire documentary about like
transphobia and that's only going to be
appealing to [ __ ] transphobes and
people that are like
sick little freaks like we are that love
[ __ ] politics and engage with it all
the time but it's not going to like this
the stevedores are not running around
being like yo bro you see that [ __ ]
matt walsh the documentary yeah that
[ __ ] was crazy bro like no no one gives
a [ __ ] about this in the in the real
world
yeah
right i mean i agree with this just the
daily wire has a lot of audience it has
a huge audience no for sure and they
have a lot of money and they definitely
pump out this agile problem they're just
entrenching people you know they're just
arming the sick twisted freaks that
really care about this stuff with
talking points so they can be sick
twisted annoying little debate perverts
ultimately ultimately it's just so
ironic because
these guys are all about personal
freedom and and liberty and all this
[ __ ] why the [ __ ] do you care what these
people how these people want to live
their lives they're not harming anyone
well they create this lie that they're
grooming children to justify hating them
yeah which guys come on here's ben
shapiro this is like this was one of the
best things that happened all week
[ __ ] um fox news
ran a really kind of beautiful
um
story on a young transgender boy
who transitioned and basically the
family's journey
to learning about tran trans issues and
and helping
their son transition
and it's it's actually a really nice
story yeah where kind of everyone comes
out for the best and matt walsh and ben
shapiro absolutely lose their [ __ ]
mind
like literally they were like i cannot
believe that there is like a 14 year old
trans boy who hasn't killed himself
that is unacceptable we need to stop
that we need to put an end to that right
now because that's precisely what
they're going to say you'll see in the
[ __ ] so they go they matt walsh first
of all tweeted this out i've appeared on
fox news many times i appreciate the
platform they given me
if what i'm about to say ruins that
relationship so be it we have to call
this evil lunacy out whenever we see it
especially on our side
um
this would be absolute despicable and
insane lunacy that's ben shapiro yeah
go ahead why do you guys think that they
ran this i was a little baffled so fox
news has uh so this is like uh one of
the local anchors i think uh oh and also
fox news has like this weird barometer
where
it's like more real news the the further
away you get from prime time like they
start with like normal news broadcasting
in the morning with the exception of fox
and uh fox5 yeah or fox and friends
sorry yeah and then the closer you get
to tucker carlson prime time the the
more psychotic it gets they dial it up
but it's like it's live it's like the
tide of insanity yeah i get that it
comes in
fox news the website is kind of like cnn
like there's a slant there's a
conservative slant to it but they're for
the most part doing uh relatively
objective news coverage as much as you
can fox news commentary on the other
hand is completely a different demon the
op-ed the actual fox news that we all
know right and appreciate is is totally
separate uh same with polling fox news
is polling uh uh
and data analysis side is actually legit
it's a legit poster that like uh you
know even the likes of nate silver uh
appreciate and agree is like a pretty
solid poster
but the commentary side is what's
popular and the commentary side is the
only thing that they're known for and
that is the propaganda arm of the
republican party
um yes this is happening in the morning
by like a random news crew that decided
to post this and it's pretty nice i mean
it's a it's a wonderful video it is
definitely perfectly crafted for even
conservatives who may or may not have
like trans relatives or something like
that to
understand especially they're really
nice
golden retrievers you know what i mean
like they're straight up the the whitest
waspiest [ __ ] family they're all
beautiful they're christian they're
christian they're conservative it's a
really nice story ben shapiro had this
to say this would be absolutely
despicable insane lunacy if i saw it on
cnn or msnbc
but to see it on fox news is a complete
betrayal of anything remotely resembling
conservatism or decency
uh by the way just to pro i mean this
this whole he lost his mind 1.7 million
views on this whole
i'm glad that they posted the actual
thing because the video is beautiful and
it's great the video shows them in a
really positive light the video even
openly it showcases like the family the
parents being like we're conservative so
originally we were like i don't
understand this and i don't like this
like yeah they they show the journey
that they went through
and people tried to sit them down and
like explain to them how this works and
how they avoided the suicide of their
child and and of course because it's so
effective in showing the humanity of a
trans person and their family especially
to a conservative audience ben lost his
[ __ ]
mind at this the crazy thing is in the
doc in this short clip they say
our son was doing self-harm and suicidal
yeah and we wanted we would rather have
a live stream a live son than a dead
daughter yeah and ben's like [ __ ] these
freaks
yeah
i'd rather have a dead [ __ ] daughter
yeah no it could float or die
it it's beautiful it's beautiful how
much he continues
he keeps going like how many tweets he
has on it dude yeah you know he [ __ ]
lost his mind dude he's frothing every
element of his video is propaganda's
dangerous garbage the report states that
this biologically female child was
choosing her gender before she could
speak this is madness the report further
states that rylan's parents began social
transition at the age of five this is
child abuse the vast majority of
children who display signs of gender
dysphoria desist over time okay so
here's the thing
what he's mentioning there
is uh is a little bit of mountain bailey
okay what he's fundamentally doing is
like of course children at the at those
formative years uh don't exactly
understand their own gender or where
gender is it's social conditioning which
is obviously the truth that they're
trying to hide away from and in that
situation some kids want to play with
[ __ ] barbies that doesn't mean
they're gay and that doesn't mean
they're trans they just want to play
with [ __ ] barbies you know what i
mean or dress up or play dress-up that
doesn't mean they're trans or gay that
just means they want to dress up but
then some of those kids are actually
trans some of those kids are actually
gay and ben wants to make sure that
those kids cannot be comfortable with
identifying with what their sexuality is
and cannot be comfortable with and
accepted in society ben wants those
incapable of finding his own [ __ ]
business yeah he's like no
a kid didn't want to kill themselves
like i'll [ __ ] that government stay out
of people's life unless it's forcing
women to have birth or forcing children
to [ __ ] kill themselves yeah it's
just
it's insane it's so insane i mean the
texas cps law is like
the the perfect example of this
department of health like uh in texas
literally has to inform the authorities
so parents go to jail if they have a
trans child like yeah you think that's
great you think that's a good idea you
[ __ ] freak so keep keep reading this
keep reading this
um the report is absolute horrifying
propaganda we got mom citing her
christian faith to justify the uh the
perversion of a biological identity
we've got the radical gender theory
activist trevor project stats claiming
that childhood transition is the only
way to prevent suicide that's empirical
evidence that he is just straight up
going over
doing my feelings actually matter more
than the facts yep that's true the
radical the radical trevor identity
project
uh the trevor project uh you know
radically trying to lower the rate of
like lgbt suicide radical poor
acceptable oh my god yeah at a certain
point it's like
it's weird to just be like um i'm
actually expressly against saint jude's
like i can't believe that they're trying
to stop children with cancer from
getting cancer and surviving cancer
that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah i wanted them to have cancer this
is a this is a great line he goes i'd
rather have a living son than a dead
daughter is again propagandist
sloganeering there's no credible
evidence that transitioning alleviates
suicidal ideation among children who
identify as lgbtq force but that made it
up yeah that that's that's actually been
proven yes there's like a lot of data
actually it's not even that shows he's
completely lying about not even that it
is even the barrier that he's lying is
so ridiculous because the barrier is is
even lower than that it is one accepting
parent like one accepting member of a of
the immediate family member of a trans
person reduces suicidality by a gigantic
[ __ ] margin
so like yes of course uh being able to
take hormones uh hormone uh
puberty blockers uh undergoing like uh
puberty blockers which are reversible by
the way okay uh is is
like
fundamentally helping trans people um
it's just so so incredibly messed up
that they are trying to stop this from
happening it's kind of nauseating
honestly i mean this is violence it's
it's violence and it's it's actually
just nauseating i mean this is evil
here's the example i use all the time
okay
ben is not a christian scientist he's
not a christian uh scientist who
believes like you need to pray uh you
know cancer away or some [ __ ] his wife
is literally a [ __ ] doctor so him
making these arguments is so insane
because you're making this argument
against medicine okay what you are
dictating in this circumstance is like
if for example if you're if you're
diabetic since birth if you have a
genetic predisposition if you have a
genetic condition and you're diabetic
ben is like i don't think you should get
an insulin pump i think you should die
when you're in the room with a sugar
cube you should be murdered because god
wanted you to be dead you should if you
didn't want to die from diabetes then uh
how about you fix your insulin levels on
your own naturally and it's like that
you can't if you were to make that
argument about any other medical
procedure people look at you go what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you man shut the [ __ ]
up but when it comes to trans people
because of how normalized uh transphobia
is because of how structured and rigid
our understanding of gender is and and
uh it seems like almost infallible
impossible to [ __ ] combat
regardless of what the actual medical
science is regardless of what the actual
biological sciences say uh that people
agree with it they they completely go
along with this kind of propaganda it's
just kind of wild how he's just
blatantly lying he continues we've got
dad talking about living authentically
by hormonally transitioning a biological
female child
transition that have continued will
result in biological sterilization or
breast and genital mutilation surgery
i'm loved that he's so worried about
their welfare this family became famous
in 2014 when they're doing that other
thing again by the way
every
every surgical process can be excre can
be described in excruciating and
gruesome detail like that you could do
that about everything open heart surgery
you're breaking someone's chest apart
you're breaking their [ __ ] rib cage
pulling their [ __ ] it all has and
literally handling their [ __ ] heart
okay that is a gruesome process but if
you were to just imagine how badly they
want to transition like they're willing
to risk whatever the [ __ ] you know but
like but my point is you can
propagandize every other medical
surgical procedure in this exact same
capacity but if you were to do it about
any other thing everyone be like that's
[ __ ] psychotic shut the [ __ ] up this
is a necessary surgery um so again he's
doing that [ __ ] there
this is like the the lineup of all the
most like common conservative tropes
against uh uh you know against like uh
trans uh trans kids existing here's a uh
this is a peer-reviewed paper
right i'm assuming yes and i highlighted
the most basically the conclusion right
there it's called transgender health
it's the conclusion is that the tgnb
youth who reported gender identity
acceptance from at least one adult had
one third lower odds of reporting a past
year suicide attempt that's insane yeah
that's how little support they need in
this world yeah even from a peer and
acceptance from at least one period was
also associated with lower odds of
passing your suicide attempt they just
need that little amount of support in
this world where people like ben shapiro
literally
are are advocating for violence against
them he wants them to die yeah it's it's
100 true that is exactly what they're
doing uh i mean if you're if you find
yourself positioned against the against
the philanthropic organization that's
like literally expressly trying to lower
the lgbt youth suicide rate and you call
them like a bunch of activists who are
uh you know doing gender activism or
whatever the [ __ ] they're spreading the
gay agenda yeah it's no different than
being like i hate saint jude's [ __ ]
those guys okay children with cancer
should [ __ ] die they are basically
medicine is in front of god my wife is a
doctor um let me finish his his tirade
this family became famous in 2014 when
ryland now 14 was six years old mom
wrote a book about her own heroism this
isn't about the children's it's about
pushing a gender theory that victimizes
small children and this is happening on
fox news where the family is praised for
its extraordinary courage in the face of
the political politicalization of
transgender issues people are afraid of
what they do not understand the reporter
says but we do understand the agenda we
understand that this is propaganda that
trans kids that's the agenda which is
that's what inappropriate this is what i
was so confused about he goes we
understand that this is propaganda on
behalf of the destruction of children
i don't understand like this is such a
half-baked theory he goes there's there
is an agenda we understand
it's the destruction of children who
i just don't like what who's pro who
who's
who's advocating for the destruction of
children and why i just don't they
aren't the theory no they are no but
what's the theory it's half baked they
saying that
liberals there's a
an agenda
to on behalf of the destruction of
children what is the theory why do we
want to treat this right transiting our
youth okay that's the theory that
they're why
why why
um there's got to be a motive overall
moral decay western degeneracy you know
fascist propaganda that's always been
there's no motive that's what i'm saying
the whole theory is so half-baked
there's no there's no [ __ ] like
logical
even
aspect to this that could make it even
believable it's like oh well we
understand the agenda and the agenda is
that they're evil it's like
that doesn't make sense that's what
happens when your worldview is not
grounded within materialist thought if
you're idealistic if you're a liberal or
a neo-liberal like ben shapiro is um or
neil khan uh the their world view
revolves around like an ultimate the
world view revolves not around like how
society is organized around the means of
production and how commodities are
produced but instead around like uh evil
people and good people right there are
good people and they're on my side and
they're good because they believe the
things that i believe in and then there
are evil people on the evil side who
believe in the evil things because they
don't agree with me if this was nicely
where there's where this comes from if
this was a marvel movie ben and his fans
would be like i didn't find that villain
very believable
it's just
his motives were not very well fleshed
out but it is no different than their
analysis of the world is no different
than a [ __ ] marvel cinematic universe
understander or enjoyer it's the exact
same [ __ ] concept of like there are
shadowy evil figures now ben himself
obviously uh is is no fan of nazis
considering that the nazis hate him as
well because he's jewish
he's soft on nazis these days oh for
sure yeah but the point i'm trying to
get to here is that this kind of
thinking is exactly in line and is
nearly identical to
fascist propaganda that led to the rise
of nazis in nazi germany it's like
really idea that two-dimensional
uh you know moral yeah like this person
is evil that's their agenda that they're
evil which makes no sense and by the way
don't take my word for it take stephen
crowder's word for it he recently uh in
in one of his broadcasts when they were
talking about trans issues again they
literally were like well this is exactly
what led to you know the nazis actually
like children we ever watched that so
many people you should pull that up
trans existence is really possible
like that was a crazy take yeah when you
are in agreement with the nazis on the
trans issues maybe don't bring that up
as like a reasonable reason for why the
nazis got so agitated uh ben shapiro
finishes by saying fox news is too
important to conservatives to be
weaponized
on behalf of radical leftist propaganda
propaganda that aims directly at the
mental and physical health of children
they should terminate whoever is
responsible for the agit prop
abomination
so let's watch the clip and see like man
you would think like damn this is gnarly
yeah watch this clip and tell me if this
is this is child abuse okay watch this
clip and tell me there's a child abuse
you i'll just show you a bit of it okay
i'm gonna go pee while you're playing
ryland whittington is a typical southern
california teenager
and the whittingtons along with mom
hillary dad jeff and sister brinley are
a typical family the only difference
though in ryland's eyes is what this
family can mean to the tens of thousands
of kids under 18 who identify as
transgender we put our story out there
so people could
see that like there's another family out
there that
is
going through what we're going through
or there's another family who's proud of
who they are before ryland could even
speak he managed to tell his parents
that he is a boy i could just see it it
wasn't him trying to be
a brat it was like painful it was truly
painful for him to have to wear feminine
clothing and and for us constantly
telling him that you're a girl and
unlike some trans kids when rylan came
out at age five a few years later he had
the full support of his parents
initially there was some pushback from
us and trying to understand this we were
confused like most people are
we thought that gender and sexuality
were the same thing it took us a while
to figure out that those two things are
different and that children actually do
recognize their gender identity very
young some of them not all but they
listened to rylan and to hillary's
conservative faith for me it's just a
deep spiritual belief that he believed
in god and he you know created us the
way he wanted us well then yes he called
ryland just the way he is they created
you how ben shapiro sees you that's
right
this really is so nice and i mean i i'm
loathe to
give fox news any credit because they
are despicable but um this is amazing
credit credit for a nice piece yeah and
it's actually where people need to hear
it too
exactly yeah which again is just why it
i i totally understand what hassan's
saying and he's right about the opinion
section of fox news being separate from
the newsroom but even then you'd think i
agree
yeah that's great somebody in the chain
of command would have been like no we're
not we can't we can't air this but
somehow it went out
good i don't think they ever retracted
it or anything either that i saw no
i mean
but here the the the most uh powerful
part is coming up here
and they listened to families they met
in support groups there was a father who
was sitting across the table he says you
have no idea how lucky you are to be
here which kind of took me back i didn't
at that point consider myself lucky to
be there and he said you know our our
child had displayed
this gender dysphoria or this gender
misalignment that's at the same age that
ryland has and
we didn't listen and we pushed back that
pushback led that child to turn to
self-harm as a teenager which 60 percent
of trans and non-binary kids engage in
dude that should give you pause sixty
percent of trans and non-bearing area
kids the band sees that and he's like
those numbers are done
guys this is a real thing i mean these
kids are really suffering
i mean ben shapiro is a [ __ ]
monster he is he's a monster he's
literally just a monster and one
mountain he saw a happy he saw a happy
family and a happy trans son
a 14 year old who's like playing [ __ ]
nothing made him angrier with his dad
that's the angriest thing he's been all
year yeah no he lost he's like frothing
he's getting a [ __ ] answer i love
this he goes you guys are lucky to be
here i wish i did this because i didn't
believe my my child and now they're dead
or something because they committed
suicide and ben shapiro's like that's
what the [ __ ] that's what the [ __ ] is
that gets him going dude that's what the
[ __ ] is up
psycho according to the trevor project
more than 50 percent consider suicide
that for me was the turning point i
didn't want to see rylan to go through
that i'd rather have a living son than a
dead daughter i guarantee that if we had
pushed back and
done what a lot of parents do
i don't think that we would have
either one of the kids that you see
before you here today allowing him to to
live authentically and true to himself
and be who he really feels like he is
when you get to know rylan you see just
how proud and confident he is i mean
look at his mustache that story got
international attention in 2014 when a
family youtube video went viral and
hillary has since written a book called
raising ryland i never thought that i
would be known for
[Music]
this like as well as i am but
really it's just a small part of who i
am he just brushed things off his
shoulders i love that i was like this is
not like yeah this is a small part of
who i am like it doesn't need to define
my whole [ __ ] ultimately ultimately
that kid is expressing what i have heard
from so many trans members of my
community which is just like they just
want to exist bro they want to exist
without people
people constantly debating their
existence people constantly advocating
to like harm them people constantly
advocating to stop medical procedures
that would help them dramatically
improve their lives just in mind just
like overall [ __ ] trying to what
happened just what happened to minding
your own [ __ ] business isn't that
what they're all about yeah it's not
though never [ __ ] business
conservatives have never throughout time
ever been about mining their own
business that's why they advocated for
uh you know anti-miscegenation laws
that's why they advocated against like
abolishing slavery this is what
reactionaries do they claim like they're
coming at it from a point of
indifference but they use that to
justify pre-existing social constructs
that are harmful to marginalized people
when when those constructs change for
the better improving the lives of
marginalized people that's when you
truly see the real conservative agenda
which is like no [ __ ] that we got to go
back to the time when when we were
actually [ __ ] killing these people
like please immediately let's do that
why because it it hurts your feelings
because it hurts your sensibility just
remember it shakes the way you
understand the world that's so [ __ ] up
just remember every time a tr a trans
kid on a lives themselves ben shapiro
gains a new eyebrow hair
and that's a fact
peer reviewed
he moves on in his life and he's just
kind of i think everything we've been
through he's just like learned to do
that and he's
really good at it i could never do that
the whittingtons believe sharing their
story could make a lasting difference in
another child's life something they
learned from that support group father
propagandist decade freaks i'm just here
to make the ride smoother for others
you might be struggling right now but we
believe in you this family we might not
know you we might not
know where you live come on they got the
khakis on of course been lost dude and
we believe
[ __ ] freaks yeah imagine watching
that and your reaction is anger yeah
unbridled literally like it is like
watching a child like uh undergo like
cancer treatment and survive right being
like no no they should have died god
wanted you dead what the [ __ ] like it's
crazy it's chemotherapy as an
abomination yeah
i don't know if because we are low on
time we're at two hours right now i did
send you that uh uh
right yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
oh i want to watch after that i want to
watch shapiro's reaction on the show too
real fast that's no that's going to be
really long is it it's one it's wait
wait wait it's only one minute that's
for sure let's just watch it okay okay
just just hold just
just chill for a minute okay okay
what extraordinary courage displayed by
ryland his sister brinley father jeff
and mom hillary i want to thank the
whittington family for speaking to us
it's not easy particularly at a time
when fire him
hate this man
you're already pausing the transgender
issues have been politicized people are
afraid of what they do not understand
dana
more acceptance and ultimately more love
just just pure propaganda pure insane
propaganda it people people don't
eyebrows look at the thickness
what if we are afraid of is the agenda
because the agenda is garbage because
it's harming children and because it's
deliberately promoting propaganda that
is based not in science but an
ideological nonsense
opposition to judeo-christian values
christian values is not science brother
what are you saying like it's an
opportunity to science and and more
importantly it's not and therefore
opposition to uh judiciary values like
how is that scientific dog what the [ __ ]
are you saying
i mean you can't have both that's
ironically kind of post-modernist i
think traditions and mores and rules and
roles
what if that's what we are concerned
about and what if we're particularly
concerned when it starts taking over
major american conservative institutions
like fox news
if you're a fox news you should think
very seriously about whether you wish to
give a company that promotes this kind
of stuff your business yeah
baby
i i want to watch fox news i'm friends
with a huge number of people who work at
fox news including most of the hosts cap
no one's family and i know that most of
the hosts do not agree with fox news
becoming a propaganda outlet on behalf
of the most radical left agenda on this
sort of stuff
they can't there's no way they do i've
talked to many of them and i know they
don't as a matter of fact the fact that
management i assume crammed this down or
went ahead with this because this was
greenlit it was a fully produced segment
which cost fox money
it's a betrayal of fox's audience it's a
betrayal of many of the people who work
at fox that's awesome
and more than anything it's it's a it's
a
reinforcement of the deep rot that has
taken place at the core of our
institutions including in many
conservative institutions which are
either too cowardly to defend values
that matter
yeah
you you don't want kids to die coward no
he he literally wanted like foxes to be
like [ __ ] this 14 year old like i i hope
he dies and then like misgender him you
know what i mean like that's what he
wanted because he's in fact but again he
keeps talking about this agenda what the
[ __ ] is the agenda the gay agenda is
literally allowing uh gay people to be
accepted in society
will uh encourage other people in to
come out frustrating their own sexuality
and experiencing their own sexuality and
their own existence in a more
comfortable manner and that will lead to
higher rates of openly gay openly trans
people i would like to terrify 400 i
would like to ask him directly what is
the agenda like spell it out for me
because i'm telling you i'm telling you
that's not what he'll say that's not
what he'll say well i mean that is the
reality behind it but his
his spin on that reality is
you're grooming when you show up
and you're show trans people existing
like this um
well he looks like an animator this has
been oh my god this is so sick my heart
goes out like yeah this is when when ron
desantis wins in 2020 his eyebrows are
gonna [ __ ] pop off he's like super
saiyan bro like he literally the more
the more powerful he gets like [ __ ]
goku uh the more powerful he gets more
his eyebrows get bushier
i'm just sad because i know
looking like a character
oh yeah yeah
tekken yeah like paul or whatever yeah
so okay one last thing before we go
uh this is crowders and his gremlins
saying that uh
the holocaust happened because uh german
society was too uh woke
sixteen thousand
were killed in world war ii in general
right so that's crazy yeah that's that's
i didn't know it was that high i knew
the number was in the hundreds of
thousands i didn't know it was over 400
000 that were killed and by the way if
any of us could have gone back to that
day can you imagine like put yourself in
saving private ryan you're standing next
to tom hanks and you're like all right
everybody's nervous they're throwing up
and you show myself i'm like man i
really appreciate what you're fighting
for today by the way
in june of 2022 they're going to be
doing this and you showed like the kid
drag queen thing about what don't do you
know just you just said this when we
could go to the clip well then we're on
the wrong side of things they would have
been like turned boat around they were
like oh my gosh
oh my god
i didn't see the longer clip yeah oh i
only saw the shorter version this is way
worse i know i i actually i rolled it
back way earlier because i saw the clip
that went viral is coming up but the
full context is actually so much fun
let's let it rise like he's right in a
weird way like i don't think he
recognizes it because like this is not
exactly taught in schools that the nazis
were also
vehemently transphobic one of the first
book burnings like those famous book
burners that they did was actually the
robust medical knowledge regarding trans
people in in one of the libraries where
they had all of this [ __ ] uh
information about like uh transitioning
and like some of the more formative
medical research was eliminated in
germany by the nazis the first ever book
burning was trans material the nazis
hated
gay people and anyone that was neuro
divergent at all yeah i mean gay people
were had their own flair in the
concentration camps so it's not like
they were like specifically like oh
we're not woke they [ __ ] hated anyone
who wasn't like normal which is on uh or
normal quote-unquote which is like
straight and white yeah and and and you
know
and christian and um
and that's a lot like them in a way in
it no it's exactly like that and he's
literally saying
like if i was born in [ __ ] germany i
would be i would
die baby yeah he's like i want to switch
sides because he said that yeah he said
he would [ __ ] turn the boat around i
would agree with a [ __ ] nazi what do
you need to hear well there's there's a
lot more like that if i said something
like that oh my god dude i'm turkish
that's way worse than american dessert
911. [ __ ] yeah but conservatives have so
much leeway because they own patriotism
right so they can be patriotically the
least patriotic you can ever be man if
if i was an american soldier fighting
for democracy against fascism i would
have dropped my gun boy if i saw
transgender youth
i swear boy i would have i would have
become a concentration cap guard myself
oh literally that's what he's saying
like if i saw the nazis murdering trans
people and i saw i'd say give me the
switch
hitler let me work that switch there
hitler
oh
we don't believe in everything but
mostly they were right yeah they've been
like so look okay pearl harbor he just
said the nazis were right yeah
that's great it keeps accelerating too
yeah until until crowder realizes what
they're saying and suddenly does he's
like oh wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait we're not yeah what
i said i got a band these guys are
saying i wish i was a
exterminator and a
in a a concentration
dude i love that thank you thank you
stephen crowder for just [ __ ] putting
out this bile every day here we go
susan wojcicki for letting this happen
yeah yeah it's part of the agenda yeah
but uh
there's the bay area over there
this is uh take that area we were
blaming the jews what was our fault all
along i can't believe that he said this
was the jews but
this is actually like really severe like
i made up these things about the jews
you're actually doing this
you're actually having
five-year-olds hand dollar bills into
your panties hold on hold that positive
first again you know what's really funny
hitler was a bit of an ameriboo and
literally like looked to the jim crow
south and the american eugene movement
right and like took a lot of note from
that right henry ford famous fascist uh
big advocate for anti-semitism uh you
know uh but american industrialist you
know so he's great uh
that's so it's it's true the germans did
at least hitler certainly did learn a
lot from america and i learned it from
you dad
yeah yeah the bracero program
the reserve program during world war one
is like uh uh is is the gas chamber like
uh is the is
like what uh uh
gas chamber this is scary dude oh no
let's say hypothetically i was only
using uh 10 of my power getting
somewhere stronger no we can't he's too
powerful
somebody trimmed those eyebrows
it's the source of his power it's just
too much it's too much all right let's
let's blast through this we're almost
there we're almost to the to the
capstone yeah this is too much they make
the jews signed a treaty like okay
listen we will release you on the terms
that you are now the uh gestapo for all
the drag events yeah
can you imagine the the earnest parts
where he's like he better invent like a
better light bulb or something like that
is like he better make sure that
the the trans community can go out and
have kids walk the stage with him you
better do something like that yeah
hitler's just like oh what is this
decadent lifestyle
why i'm going to paint it
their bands are the worst
surrealism he's like no this is real
it's happening no it comes it becomes
this look i i dress like this just in
drag wait he's saying hitler
this kind of culture developing in
germany now let's be clear of course oh
hitler was in part a response to this
kind of culture developing in germany
now let's be clear of course
you are all defending hitler there oops
you are kind of fans admit your kind of
fans he's like oops just realize we've
been banting about how hitler was done
five minutes kind of base that was you
we all saw it yeah
we all saw it let's watch him try to
backpedal it the only point that he
would jump on board with it because he's
an awful lot he's an awful yeah being
probably the worst in human hands he
would have been a but yes hitler would
have been a self [ __ ] clothing yes
drag dancer whoa whoa whoa
literally [ __ ] saying he's a hitler
dude he's a self-loathing
crossbow i don't think he's i don't
think he's trans but like he is across
cross dresser yeah yeah yeah you know
listen first time you do it for a bit
for a little bit of a gaff and a goof
you know that's fine you do it like
eight times bro that's what you like
that's a package that's your [ __ ]
king that's a hobby that's a hobby yeah
yeah it's not even a kink at that point
it's just like how you yeah
you're expressing your real you
hitler
most like hitler one could argue anyway
yeah you guys are bigger yeah and the
rest of it is like them trying to be
like hitler was actually pro trans yeah
oh yeah
you asked for the three xl so all right
let's see this is the women's uh yeah by
the way we are we are moving to make
everything um unisex again oh let's go
so that'll be but let's see how
hassan
fits in the 3xl let's take a look here
this ain't happening
[Music]
so uh he is taking off he's taking it
off
oh our audience is i like your show oh
that shirt
[Music]
here we go
let's see how this goes
this is that's the 3xl
kind of a vibe over the shirt that's
dope bro go down a little bit it's kind
of the vibe
i'm not hating it
i'm not hating it
i mean i can wear it
terrible i can wear it yeah yeah and
then here here's the other thing you
requested a little bit yeah
thank you what is oh this is the this
guy's just like merged yeah you guys
just did the fusion dance it kind of
looks dope from the top up when you
can't see that it wouldn't oh it's if
it's longer it'd be if you remind me of
some anime guy who like is super jacked
that doesn't fit into his clothes yeah i
mean you stream sitting down i don't
notice yeah true
yeah i expect you to wear that
here it is
[Applause]
uh
necklace that's like uh wait that's the
necklace yeah i don't know if that's
gonna fit around your neck see i i wear
chokers
okay um
i didn't realize it was all wrapped in
plastic i'm sorry about that i saw it
come
yeah comes in this like plastic thing
that dude
it's literally the strongest plastic on
the i don't know what's going on there
it's hard to take off man but i will say
that uh as we wrap it up here thanks for
watching
we should say that um we had we
postponed the interview oh yeah yeah i'm
sorry to um
the union
girl from starbucks who we had we're
gonna have his guests we ran out of time
but we'll have her call in next week she
said it's no problem i'm very sorry she
says no problem and uh we'll work it out
for next week okay sounds good yeah i'm
very sorry to her
and by the way tomorrow we have an
insane
episode lined up you guys do not know
it's a banana episode it's a bang
really wrap that in dude i don't know
it's the most powerful why are they
doing that of all time dude
stronger than ben shapiro's eyebrows
even yeah i need ventrabiro's eyebrow
power right now to [ __ ] take this off
what the hell i probably did it wrong
though i mean but why did they come like
that stickier
to protect it keep it fresh keep it
fresh
just but there's like a nice bag it
comes in you don't need to wrap it in
plastic do you
um i mean it's your company ethan i just
didn't know they were doing that i know
this okay here it all came off when i
like figured out one there we go okay
hopefully it fits wait how do you
oh that the lock has a little sliding
mechanism there
wait it does yeah it opens from the from
the lock
thing there's a
no there's no like or anything for it
wait let me see
oh we're gonna merge again
oh
[Music]
what
[Music]
no no go back a little bit yes yes yes
yes oh my god
what would your guy's fusion name yeah
what's the fusion name
a fan
how's than how's that
[Music]
no no ethan you stick out your arm to do
the the weird bendy arm
thing oh my god this is like when you
[ __ ] up oh look at that
put it down a little bit
does his arm look bad not as bad as mine
it's similar this double jointed as well
can you do the like the thumb thing
i don't know i don't think i'm double
jointed i think it's just a camera this
is like when you [ __ ] up the fusion
dance yeah
that's good all right well thanks for
watching you know
good tide
vile times though but anyway join us
tomorrow it's friday
uh it's the leftovers guys underground
you will never find us
ever don't try don't even try
don't do it
we got turds
[Music]
all right guys hope you enjoy we'll see
you tomorrow it's friday baby
have a good day see you later see ya
[Music]
you